Welcome back!
Hello!
I feel like I'm on a beach vacation with this music.
Is this a chill game?
Guys...
Small Minto.
Today, I'm small.
It's been a while since we've had chibi Minto, so...
Do I have to do the tutorial?
Or will it let me still join?
What do you mean today in quotes?
What do you mean by that?
Chibi Minto.
Could be useful.
Let me ask.
Should I do the tutorial first?
I'll ask them.
How long is it?
It's optional, but probably useful.
Tutorial speedrun.
The girls will explain?
You think so?
I'm not graduating!
Stop it!
Stop!
Small and cute.
Thank you so much for 3-5.
Thank you!
They're not responding to me.
I was actually wondering.
I was like, did I get the time right?
Streaming with...
Collabing with Twitch people is scary.
Because they just like...
Are so...
Relaxed about everything.
They're like...
Oh, Matara said no need.
Limes will explain.
She's very kind like that.
Okay.
I love Lime.
She's so nice.
Unlike Matara-kun.
But...
Yeah, it's like...
So strange.
Because they'll be like, oh yeah.
They'll just collab.
And they're already streaming.
And I just started streaming.
But people on Twitch are like, I've been streaming for 5 hours.
And I'm just gonna do a collab.
That's just so strange to me.
That's so strange to me.
I'll give you the rundown, don't worry.
It's my first time also collabing with Cinder.
So I'm a little nervous.
Because she's really pretty.
But she actually...
She...
Asked me.
I was like...
You wanna...
You wanna collab with me?
That's how I felt.
I was like...
Co...
Collab...
With...
Bito?
Or...
Soda?
I'm...
I'm just a small ghost maid.
Why do I talk like that?
That's how I feel in my soul.
Thank you so much for the gifted!
Wait.
Oh my gosh, wait.
I feel like I've missed so many.
Thank you for the 20 gifted!
I'm looking at them at the top.
I heard you're not graduating.
Yeah, I'm not graduating.
I did not pass my classes.
I didn't pass my classes, you guys.
I'm not graduating.
You know how they said C's get degrees?
Well, they lied!
They lied!
Wait, did you see Matara's joke about you in her going live post?
Comedy gold.
Wait, what did she say?
Matara Khan.
What did she say?
In my post?
You guys, I hit 200k on Twitter.
That's craziness.
I replied to it.
Oh, that post.
Tuna, I'm gonna murder you.
No, I'm not gonna murder you.
I'm gonna turn you into sushi.
And then I'm gonna consume you.
And get mercury poison.
I thought you meant on my...
I took a break from social media and now I hear you're graduating.
No!
I'm not graduating, please!
Can we get 200k big booms for the 200k followers on Twitter?
Ok, this might take a while.
Pretty!
Thank you so much for the 50 gifts.
Don't threaten him with a good time.
You're right, you're right, you're right.
Ok.
Whoever wants to call first.
I'm shy.
Limelight.
Ok, I'm gonna join the call everybody.
I'm gonna join the call.
Oh, everybody is already in but me.
Ok, I'm joining the call.
Hi!
Cinder, you're so low for me.
Why?
Oh, am I?
Oh, it was... Discord put you at 67%.
How would it do that?
Oh no!
Wow, she's got me...
No!
You just met and she already hates you.
I know!
Why did they put you at such an arbitrary number?
I don't get it.
Wait, I don't hear Lime.
Wait, Lime is muted.
Oh my gosh.
Oh, she's got me muted too!
I hate Lime!
Mint, I had you muted and I was sitting there like, why is Mint muted?
And then you had me muted too.
Lime just hates all of us.
No, I've got everybody else unmuted.
It's just Mint.
Damn.
It's nice to meet you, Mint.
Nice to meet you.
I'm so excited for today.
I've never played this game.
Nice to meet you too, Mint.
It's been a while.
Yeah, it's been a while.
You're a stranger to me now.
I told them that we had like a nice long talk on Friday?
Or Thursday, I forgot.
When did we have a catch up call?
I don't remember.
It was several hours.
Yeah.
It was...
Oh, it lasted three hours.
That's short for us.
Damn!
Sometimes you just need some girl talk.
We also haven't really had the chance to talk in a bit.
So, nice to meet you, Mint.
Nice to meet you.
Nice to eat you.
That's my Lime.
I know.
You stole my Lime earlier!
Okay, you just...
Your Lime was calling me not cute.
Like, that's not original.
And you're not original, okay?
You've never been original!
Sorry, Cinder.
For this very embarrassing display.
She can't be professional.
I'm so sorry.
I've never seen the side of her before.
I can be professional.
You started it!
She started it.
She tweeted.
Cinder Lime.
She tweeted instead of collaborating with you girls and Matara.
She started it.
I'm just continuing it.
Drama!
She broke my house in Minecraft.
What?
No, I would never.
She hurt me emotionally.
It's an all out war now.
Yeah.
War.
No, war.
Give war a chance.
Yeah, so...
It's gonna be a lot of fun.
You'll see repo mint.
I think it'd be easier than lethal.
Yeah, you said that.
I feel like it's easier because the...
I feel like the monsters are less sort of like...
Oh, you got this guy?
You die.
There's less of that going on.
There's also very...
There's a lot of opportunities to revive each other.
Which is good.
Oh, okay.
And eventually too...
Yeah, like you said with the monsters.
You can kill a lot of the monsters and you can hide and still escape a lot of the monsters.
So...
That was so crazy.
Every night before bed I scroll through TikTok and I've been getting repo videos recommended to me that's like tips and tricks on how to defeat this monster.
So you're a pro now.
You're a pro.
We'll see if I can execute any of them.
But yeah.
Okay, I can't wait to watch.
Okay, who's gonna host by the way?
Who's like in the middle?
Is it Manta again?
I think it's, yeah, me or Cinder maybe.
Whatever is easiest.
Let me open repo.
Cinder, do you want to host?
Since you're the one who organized.
Sure.
I'm just launching my game.
Oh, and it's just really silly.
The way the characters look in game it gives you so much serotonin.
Oh, you're gonna love it.
You guys remember the old android mascot?
Like the foes?
Yes, the little green guy!
Yeah, it reminded me of that.
I never had an android.
I'm sorry.
I had a blackberry into an iPhone.
That's so VTuber USA, Manta.
Wait, wait, wait.
Are we talking about non-iPhones?
That's awesome.
I love that.
Yeah, non-iPhones.
I had an android.
You know what I had?
I had this phone called an HTC ChaCha and it had like a physical keyboard and a Facebook button.
And a fucking dedicated Facebook button.
Just in case you really want to go on Facebook.
Who doesn't?
I love seeing AI generated anything on there.
It's really depressing.
The only thing I follow...
I've had a long day.
The only thing I follow on Facebook is pet breeders, so specifically the lady I got my ferrets from and then a couple of Pomeranian breeders.
Half of the things now recommended to me are Pomeranian or ferret related accounts that just post AI.
Some of them even have Pomeranians and ferrets and instead of posting pictures of the actual animals they're posting AI.
No!
Do they just not realize?
Is it one of those like they don't realize it's AI or?
Oh no, it's like they specifically generated it because they wanted to be like...
They'll do one where it's like, Merry Christmas everybody!
Oh no, this is my favorite.
They went, Merry Christmas everybody and then they had like an AI generated image of a Pomeranian with ice skates on an ice rink.
And a few people in the replies were like, So talented!
How did you get it to do this?
I don't want to interrupt but it looks like you're not online on Steam live.
Am I not online or are we not officially friends?
Mint, can you do me a favor?
We've done like 18 million things how are we not friends?
I don't see you!
Oh my god!
I just said my friend code in the chat!
I'm editing you!
Don't listen, we're great friends!
Oh no, we usually play Switch stuff.
Yes, that's why I've sent you an invite.
Mint, can you go...
Am I not getting 18 million friend requests because you just showed it on stream?
Wait, did I?
I don't know, you said nobody saw this.
Oh, are you talking about the fact that...
Okay, for a minute I was like on top of everything else, you just linked my code.
Okay...
Huge drama.
Okay, I'll mute in here.
What the?
I think you have to press T.
What was that?
There's text-to-speech.
Press T, Mint.
T.
Just for the record, if you die and you guys are together dead, you can also do the text-to-speech chat while you are dead.
Is it also T when you're dead, or...
You sound like little ghosts, it's like little whispers.
Yeah, it is still T to open the chat.
We're laughing a little hard at this.
How's the audio, everybody?
Soundcheck, soundcheck.
Soundcheck.
Start with Cinder.
Stop laughing at me!
Sorry.
He's making fun of me.
I'm so sorry.
If you could not laugh at Cinder's brand, that would be great.
You're so cute.
Okay, what does the Mataracan say?
I'm gonna eat you.
Mint, you're next.
What did you say?
I don't know, I guess my thing is like thank you, thank you.
That's my thing.
We'll just combine everybody.
Yeah, so thank you, thank you, is what we got so far, I think.
I'm gonna eat you.
I also like on these things how the mouth goes more depending on how loud you are.
Well, if you ladies are done screaming, we can start our game.
Cinder, I'm sorry.
We lose brain cells being next to one another.
Girl, literally me.
Anytime I'm doing anything.
I'm scared.
I volunteered Limes to explain the game to Mint.
That's fine.
I like explaining things.
Okay, here we go.
Hello.
Okay, Mint.
The big things to know are shift to run, the energy refund, or sorry, regen is fucking awful though, so only use it in an emergency.
Control to crouch, and you can get under objects if you sprint towards an object and crouch you will slide under the object which is important when running away from things.
Q to go really, really tiny.
In this form you can fit into lots of tiny things and people can also pick you up which is very cute.
You can also...
You have to press Q.
There she goes.
Woooo!
It's like she's a ghost!
You can see what it looks like.
Get me out of here.
Okay, there we go.
If you want to pick me up, you can see what it looks like.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Hold left click.
Can I throw it?
Minty, did you ever play Half-Life with the gravity gun?
Oh, no I didn't.
Okay, well that's basically what you have.
It's physics based.
You can launch things and move things around.
When you pick stuff up you can use your mouse wheel to move them closer and further away like this.
And then if you right click you can rotate them.
Like this.
Other important things to know...
Oh, if you're a Zentraya you need to know if you run and then jump and then press Q, you like tumble into your friends and hurt them.
Also there is...
There is...
It doesn't actually hurt them, but it knocks them.
Nice job.
So you first then jump or what?
Wait, so I run...
Run, jump, Q.
Do it!
Hit me!
First try.
Yay!
Other important things to know...
I think if you fold down and then use text to speech and then move your cursor around the pitch of the text to speech changes, which is very important.
Oh.
What's the objective?
We're just getting money?
You can also touch her by the way.
Yeah, so if you see in the upper right corner we've got zero heads down.
Okay.
Sorry.
Okay, so yeah, it's like lethal.
We need to get a certain amount of salvage in order to get out.
This is our little cart.
We're going to be taking this around.
It's for holding things.
We need to take our salvage over here.
It's a good idea if you can to overstock the salvage, but you don't want to put it all on until you're ready because as soon as you get past the threshold, it will crunch down and take everything.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
The big issue is all the items we collect are breakable, so if you damage them, it loses value.
Yeah, that's where the physics thing is in, so you have to be careful not to hit each other and objects with stuff.
Some stuff is more delicate than others.
Can I take anything?
If you hold tab, you can see your map.
On the map, they come up as little yellow dots.
Try opening the door, Minty.
Try opening the door.
That's not how you open a door, but...
Sorry, I don't know my own strength.
What is that?
That's really unfortunate.
That's one of the hardest enemies in the game.
Well,
I hope Mint enjoyed her first time in the game.
That was fun.
I think he's laughing at us.
Did Cinder survive?
I don't know, but we need to find her next item.
Why did she sound like that?
Cinder, the clone is here.
Be careful.
The clone's coming.
I got him.
Why
did I die so fast?
Are they like noise activated?
This is so unfortunate, Mint.
Don't laugh at my body.
Stop it!
Stop laughing at me!
That's me.
The crying emoji is me.
It's actually really unlucky.
We got the hardest boss in the game as the first guy.
I'm so sorry.
That's okay.
We're going to try to revive you, Aesop.
Aesop, don't hide.
Revive me!
Don't just laugh.
What?
What is it?
These are the special items.
Hey guys, while I let the clown away, were you being super productive and getting lots of loot?
Let's try to revive her, Aesop, and get out of here because clown guy.
I'm scared.
Let's grab some more things really quick.
Poor Mint.
Ball!
There's a text-to-speech system.
I know, I used it.
Hello.
Tara is doing her job.
Take you to the supermarket or something?
And you would sit in the cart?
Come sit in my cart, Cinder.
Okay, I will take you on a shopping trip.
You have to be careful because the clown will...
The clown will...
You don't want to put that in the cart, Tara?
No, I want to go bring it back because I'm scared he's going to mess it up.
He's going to mess it up.
Right?
Like the clown can just mess things up.
Poor Mint, I want her to play.
Poor Mint.
Can you type yours in?
Why is this so scary sounding?
Wow,
she's missing superchats, you guys.
So am I, though.
Sorry.
I'm not even playing the game.
I'm here.
Sad.
I didn't even get to play the game for two seconds.
I didn't even get to play for even a second.
We only have one area this time around.
What if I...
Wait, is it like Little Company where I revive...
After each round?
Hello, Mintle.
Hello.
How's the repo experience?
I'm a passenger princess right now.
I'm so...
Take it.
Oh, they're laughing at us.
Wait, why is my head there?
Yeah, I'm pampered.
You can revive every time, too.
I'm back!
What happened?
Is he?
How do you know he's coming back?
I see him.
He's right here.
Because he's right there!
Hi!
Duck, duck, duck!
I died.
I got to watch you guys play though, so that was fun.
In future rounds, Mint, you get to bring the card in several times.
So if you die, we can revive you and then you can still play.
Okay.
So it's really, really fun.
If we meet him again, he can only do his laser beam at one height.
So if he starts at an average height because we're standing, just immediately...
Yeah, immediately go down.
If he starts low, jump.
Or get on a box or some shit.
26.
I'm gonna take this strength upgrade.
This is mine, I wanna be strong.
Sure.
I don't need it.
Who would hurt me?
I think, okay, so if she gets a health upgrade, she'll have 120 health.
And that will give her 20 more.
So she actually could take this one, it's just as good.
Yeah, cause that way she'll get like 20 bonus to everything.
And she'll need the extra health.
Cinder, would you like a little stamina upgrade, my love?
Sure.
And I will take one too.
I feel like we could always use more stamina.
It's been so long to regen.
You wanna press the button?
We have enough, nice, nice, nice.
Yeah, yeah, you wanna press the button, Mint?
Come here, come here, come here, girl.
I'm pressing.
Push the button, push it, push that button.
Nice.
Oh, what's happening?
Yippee, they're gonna be on the ship.
Oh, finally.
Those are our purchases.
Hurry!
Yay!
You'll see, you'll get the hang of the game pretty quickly.
Okay, I will.
Cause if you stand in the box, it's gonna kill you.
It will?
Yup.
Yeah.
You guys have...
They're so nice.
You guys didn't tell me to like do it.
You didn't haze me.
It's got a bunch of enzymes.
Oh, we'll haze you, don't worry.
We'll worry, don't worry.
Okay, Mint, take the green box and then press E when you're holding it.
Okay.
Yippee!
Where are we going now?
Are y'all ready?
We're going to a new place.
Taxman.
Oh, Latara Khan.
She's texting.
What are those emojis mean, huh?
Me?
Can you send like one of those like thirst emoji sentences to the...
Eggplant.
Yeah.
Sweaty.
Water.
Tongue sticking out.
Yeah.
So, very quickly also, Mint.
If you saw on the thingy, I was bringing stuff back here.
Usually we try to bring the big stuff or the stuff that breaks in one hit.
Cause once like enemy, for example, the clown when he used his laser.
If that had hit the cart, the stuff that breaks in one hit would've broke him.
Wow!
What?
Alex Malico.
Let me grab your neck.
Maybe I should put that on the extraction point because once we...
If we have to pick this up, it's going to break everything.
How do you know what's grabable?
Ok, so I will show you.
Come with me.
So first of all, click on this door.
Yeah.
And I'll open it fully.
Always try to open the doors to like their fullest.
I'm opening.
Then it's easier to come in and out.
Yep.
Oh, candlelit dinner.
Ok.
Oh, Mint.
Mint.
This diamond will break in one hit.
Oh, ok.
Good luck.
Careful.
I'm careful.
Mint!
Don't drop it.
Yeah.
Put it in the cart.
In the cart.
How do I drop it nicely?
Yeah, just put it down a bit and then just let go.
Good girl!
Yay!
So if you come here, Mint, you'll see the cart.
It says 3,400.
Oh, yeah.
There's another object on this shelf.
And you can also like carry the cart too.
If you want to try that.
Just get like used to it.
It hovers.
Nice.
Easy.
Another thing here is the lockers.
Like always try to open the lockers.
And also like try to look above.
Metal gear.
They might have posters.
They might have posters, yeah.
But always try to open them and jump to see sexy women.
Wives.
Okay.
But yeah, right now it's like fairly easy because it's the early levels.
There's a lot of watches here.
Gotta be careful.
Go pick up some stuff.
I am.
I'm going.
Is there anything else in here?
You're doing great.
Thanks!
How do you know when to pick something up?
Yeah, there could be men.
What is this thing?
This might be the sexy women in the lockers.
Looks kind of like a chicken.
Not gonna lie.
Hello?
Math?
Game is horror.
What's that sound?
Why do I hear music?
Hi.
I'm sure it's nothing.
Oh, okay.
Oh, plate.
Oh, oh.
Um...
Sorry.
My bad.
There's more stuff here.
Oh, guys!
Doll!
Okay, so do you see the minuses?
That's because she's breaking...
Move the card back.
The doll.
Backpack back the other way.
Oh!
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
We'll be back home?
Yeah, as most...
Because if she attacks us...
Actually...
Under the table.
Oh, under the table.
I'm here.
I'm grabbing her, but I don't think I can like...
Oh, can we go back and get that saw blade?
Oh, she's hitting me!
Oh, no!
I'm gonna...
Oh, she can reach us under the table.
Oh, she can?
Oh, uh...
I'm gonna take this stuff back.
Let's sneak.
She's screaming.
I got it.
You got the card?
Okay, I'll be on the lookout...
for anything in our way.
Okay.
I got the card.
I'm doing my part.
Alright.
I love how we're whispering.
There are some enemies that are triggered by sound.
I don't know if...
Oh, okay.
And then we'll go back and see if they're alive...
and then we can revive them.
Yeah!
They're probably dead.
Of course I'm alive.
What the heck?
Just kidding.
Of course they're alive.
Okay, and then...
I cannot say the same for Matara.
I don't know where Matara is.
No.
She better die.
I thought that was her head.
No, I don't know where she is.
I'll go look for her.
Let's go...
Yeah.
Matara Khan!
She can't stop talking...
so we'll know if she's alive immediately.
Oh, wait.
You're so right.
Oh, Mata!
Just follow the screams of terror.
No problem.
Mata!
Are you still alive?
Matara Khan!
Guys, I don't hear her.
I don't either.
I hit something behind the whiteboard over here.
Is it still there?
Oh, no!
She died?
Oh, really?
She's beheaded.
I'll take you back, Matara.
I'll take you back.
Could you grab these gems?
She's gonna lose a few brain cells on the way home, though.
Wait, I still have her?
Oh, yeah.
Come on, Matara.
Don't lag.
I want to get enough strength to be able to bludgeon that knife doll to death.
Can I do it with her head?
I don't think she's... I don't think it's a strong enough object, unfortunately.
That would be funny, though.
Like a newborn baby.
I want to buy, like, seven upgrades in strength and, like, rip a door off the frame and beat something to death with it.
I feel like a one-shot anatomy.
Should I put her head inside?
Yeah.
We have another extraction point, so we can just do this one now.
Okay.
Get her back.
Why is it so liquidy sounding?
I don't like it.
It's smooshy.
How do you rip the door off the frame?
Strong.
I'm trying.
More strength.
I need more strength.
All of us together can do it!
What's this?
Our money?
It's our excess cash.
Can you grab my neck, blinds, please, deductively?
Can you touch me?
Oh.
A little bit.
Yay!
I've been touched.
Thank you.
For once in your life.
Just because I've... Listen, you know what, bitch?
This might be the year I find the love of my life, okay?
I know he's out there.
I know he exists.
Someone wants to get eaten.
Surely that's not just hardcore coping.
No.
Yeah, surely.
Surely not.
Surely.
How would we have killed the Reaper, by the way?
Some folks are saying to throw chairs at them, but you can't pick up the chairs.
So I'm kind of curious how that could have happened.
Wait, we killed it?
No, no, no, no, no.
It's just because they move around the map.
Oh, okay, okay.
But you'll see, like, it's fairly easy to avoid a lot of monsters.
Says the person who died.
I died to the gnomes, okay?
There were little people like me there, and they hurt me.
The gnomes!
So the gnomes, what they're gonna do is they're gonna run at our treasure, and they're gonna try to break it.
So we need to, like, just take them and throw them at the wall.
Little assholes, okay.
Oh, you can grab them, okay.
Yeah.
Just like me.
I found a thing!
Extraction point.
It's the door to the left.
Okay.
Door to the left.
Oh.
I'll let you in.
I'll hold it up high.
I won't drop it on you.
Don't worry.
You can actually use that to kill the big lady if she shows back up.
Watch out.
Everybody.
I got a chainsaw.
Nice.
Ew, why is it in the bathroom?
Give me something to break!
How about your fucking face?
Oh, the toilets can also have stuff in them.
I'm trying to get in.
Nothing.
I don't believe her.
Okay, we'll have to come back for this if we find another enemy.
Because this could be useful.
Oh my god.
Wait, wait, careful.
I have a diamond.
Can I drown?
Or is that not possible?
Are you crouching in the toilet, Mint?
I don't know if this one has a flush.
Hold on.
Oh, it does.
Alright, bye.
Almost died, I think.
Hey buddy, you're fine.
I'm just a little stinkier than before.
What are you doing behind there?
I'm hiding from the... I'm reading also...
Chat is telling me how to kill the clown.
I saw something on the left there.
Be careful.
So I'm just learning how to kill the clown.
I didn't know you could actually open the toilets.
Here, flush me, flush me.
Flush me, flush me.
One second, one second, one second.
I want to make sure she's not coming in here.
Where are you?
I'm in the toilet.
Oh, I hear some issues.
What's going on?
How are you in the toilet?
Oh, you're in this toilet.
Yeah.
Okay, sorry, you look like you were Limes' color.
Get small, press Q.
Okay, hold on.
I'm going to get in the toilet.
No, you can just press Q.
I am.
I'm going to haze you.
Oh.
You little bitch.
Hold on.
That's what you get for going to Japan without me.
What?
Oh, you're going to throw me in?
No, you're going to give me a swirly.
That's what you get.
Why didn't you call me a cute girl?
Okay, okay.
Why didn't you call me a cute girl today, huh?
I can only tell truths.
Okay, okay.
Fine, fine.
You know what?
If you're not going to lie, you're going back into the toilet.
Please, Matoro.
Please, Matoro, please.
Oh, gosh.
You kicked me out of the toilet.
Did you get a swirly?
Where's the money, Lebowski?
Where's the money, Leminski?
I feel like I'm going to be...
This is my home now.
Oh, my gosh.
Did we break the toilet?
Yeah.
Damn.
Where's the money, Leminski?
Ouch.
Where's the money?
Can we get five gifted for Cinder right now?
Can we get five gifted for Cinder?
Suddenly, the game is muted.
This is so weird.
That's so crazy.
I don't know what's wrong.
Sorry, chat.
Wait, what can I pick up?
Oh, I can open the door.
Where are we going?
Oh, you can open the...
You can also open the...
I'm trying to get in.
The doors.
Yeah, I'm in.
Is that a blade?
What's that sound?
The monsters can't stop us.
That's the girl, I think.
Right?
The girl?
Hello.
Hello, little girl.
The girl.
Oh, there's a bunch of lockers here.
Two to open.
Where are you guys?
Oh, my God.
I looked through all those.
You already looked through them?
I think we got everything on the map.
Yeah, I think we got everything.
If you look through them, try to keep at least one door open.
So that way, it tells the other player that you looked through it.
I think they automatically close.
Oh, they do?
Really?
My monkey!
Can you grab my monkey?
Yeah.
Thank you.
You're welcome.
Mint, why are you touching me?
My little monkey.
Dance for me, monkey!
Dance for me!
Okay, now Mint, all the monsters respawned, so it's a great idea to run back to the ship.
If you press tab, it's going to show you where the ship is.
Oh, I think I remember.
But just in case, once this goes in, you're going to see where the ship is.
Oh, okay.
So, good luck.
Oh, we're running?
Oh, see these little gnomes?
They're going to hit you, so if you got one, just throw it at the wall.
Oh my god!
They do damage.
Thank you.
Sorry.
Kill gnome, kill gnome.
Kill Mint, kill Mint.
That's not me!
Oh, another one.
Wow, they're aggressive.
I'm out of stamina.
I don't think she can get through here.
Oh shit.
I think I'm dead.
She was so young!
I'm getting used to the controls still guys, sorry.
I'm starting to get used to the controls.
I think I was holding Q instead of just pressing it.
I gotta go get Mint's head.
Get Mint's head.
Maybe, can you lure the knife lady away?
Do I have what?
I have a gnome in my hand.
A gnome in my hand.
There's like a million of them.
Million little gnomes.
Why do they keep populating?
You're doing your best.
She's coming after me.
Oh, nice.
Distract her.
Oh fuck, the little gnome.
Oh wow.
Damn, she ganked.
She ganked, she ganked.
Looper, looper, looper.
Looper around the table.
Oh there she goes, she's aggro on it.
Uh-oh.
Uh-oh, she's...
They have me.
Oh my God!
I'm alive!
She went up my butt.
She did go up your butt.
I was hoping she wouldn't chase me that far.
If they give her time to leave, it'll be alright.
Unfortunately, I was being chased by gnomes and her.
Do you see it?
Oh fuck, I ran back the wrong way.
Yep.
There are so many gnomes.
Just run, just run to the ship.
Don't start it, I'm coming.
I think you can bash him with the head.
I'm back!
Wait, I'm alive!
How am I alive?
Because we brought her back.
She chased me so far.
We did it!
So then you press the envelope.
Guys, apparently we can dive into her when she stops swinging.
How are you enjoying it so far, Mint?
I like it.
I'm getting used to it.
You'll see it gets easier and easier.
You'll pick it up so quick.
Taxman.
Look at all our money!
Alright, we need to kind of save a little bit of money for a gun.
But before that...
I was trained by the blue.
I wish to become even stronger.
Look at me swinging that thing.
I think we can do both of us health upgrades if you want.
Yeah, I'm at 40.
Yeah, because that way this gives you 20 health.
Don't pay any attention to what I'm doing right now.
Grab the other one.
And Mint, you're going to eat the yellow one.
Okay, I'll eat the yellow.
Let's save money for the rest.
How much health are you guys at, LimesMint?
56.
16.
I think LimesMint would be AFK.
No, I'm here.
I'm here.
Hello.
What was I doing?
What am I doing?
No, I'm just asking how much health you had.
I'm going to do something very illegal.
Don't let Mint look.
Are you doing the hack?
Yep.
No.
Are you stealing?
She steal?
She stole from the store.
I stole fizzy lifting drinks.
You get nothing.
Stinder, take the green one.
Mint, take the yellow one.
I'm taking the yellow.
Hold on, but I'm donating some of it to Mint which makes it morally okay.
It's okay to steal as long as you give to others.
I got stuck donating health to her so now it's all Mint's.
You gave me some too.
Here, let me give you some back.
Thank you.
It got sticky for some reason.
Thank you very much.
Oh yeah, I can give you some.
Hold on.
Crime doesn't pay.
How do I... Oh, I have to grab your neck.
Sorry, I started it.
Yeah, it's like Robin Hood.
It's like a Robin Hood.
Don't worry.
This one is really fun with the wizards.
Wizards.
We love casting spells.
You can have some spells.
You said it was a money game.
Hello.
No!
Help!
Again!
Oh, sorry.
You have to like keep her there when she's small or she'll get out.
If she'll get out, you have to like keep her in.
Why did you say run here?
Zombies.
Oh, shadow play.
Don't run into her.
Oh, I'm on.
I'm on.
Thank you Mint.
I leave room for my lady.
We can break these locks with a sledgehammer eventually.
Oh yeah, I saw some in the first map.
No, the padlocks.
It's the headmaster.
This looks spooky.
I don't think I like it in here.
It's kind of scary in here.
It's kind of spooky in here.
It's kind of spooky scary in here.
Hello.
Jump into the cart and then go small.
It's like being at a supermarket with your parents.
Yeah, there you go.
Try slotting medium loot into monsters.
Interesting.
Thank you.
I'll have to try it out.
I'm also gonna go hide the...
Woah, there's a giant thing!
Yeah.
Will this break?
It's fragile, just gently lower it into there.
I'm very nervous.
Very good.
I don't know why I didn't do that because I have the strength upgrade, but you did a great job.
Careful guys, alcohol.
I can also bring the ball back to base if you have more space.
Why is this...
Yeah, you take the ball.
I got a shiny cup.
You're my shiny cup.
Spell I cup.
That's very breakable by the way, be careful with it.
Yeah.
Hold on.
Oh god, this is heavy.
I'm gonna drop it.
I can take it, Mata.
I can take it.
Yeah, if you don't mind.
Okay.
I might take like one strength upgrade after.
What was that?
Oh, what is that?
What is it?
Where are we running?
Who is it?
It's the head.
Why can't I go inside?
If he looks at you...
I'm trying to hide!
What did I do wrong?
Oh no!
What happened?
I was...I was...I got small but then what happened?
I was trying to get under the...
I was trying to get...I pressed Q.
I pressed Q but it would make me big again.
He jump-scared me.
He jump-scared you for real?
He came right behind me.
He's coming back, Mata.
I pressed Q but my game kept making me big again.
It's hard.
It's hard to get used to the tackling mechanics.
You gotta run and then you also jump and then you also press Q.
It's much fun to spectate.
You can use the scroll wheel to zoom in.
You can?
Yeah, you can zoom in on their faces.
Oh, Tara.
Oh my gosh, it's like dynamic camera angles.
Does he have good hearing?
Her character is a little dirty.
Or is he an old man?
Yeah.
Stinky Matara.
Is he an old man?
Let's hope they can carry us now.
Well, I've got you.
I think she's getting me.
You're like, oh boy.
Here we go again.
Oh, Q is ragdoll.
Control is crouch.
There's a lot of stuff still here but we should make another trip maybe.
Yeah, we should just move on.
Yeah, I'll get used to it eventually.
Be careful because the face kind of went in that direction.
I thought Q was the tiniest and then there's crouch and then there's tiny, tiny.
Yeah, so when you go tiny, I think you kind of fall over.
The donkey is also around.
So it's hard to move around after that.
Shit, sorry you stopped.
It's fine, it's fine.
My bad, my bad.
This thing is such a pain in the butt, this giant.
I always want to be close to you, Matara.
That's my girl.
You put it in?
Yeah.
We're coming down.
Wait, you can't tell?
Sorry, I'm just nervous.
I'm having a...
What is happening?
I definitely could tell you put it in.
I just...wrong phrase.
Hi Mint.
Hi.
Wait.
OK, you hang out in the crate with your giant sack of money.
There you go.
OK, I'm still learning the controls.
So I think I get it.
You're doing great, baby.
Joe Biden, Joe Biden, Joe Biden.
Back it up, back it up, back it up.
This is Skull.
Hide under the bench here, if you need to.
I will see what he's doing.
OK.
Yeah, for some reason Mata calls him Joe Biden.
I have one HP.
Joe Biden, Joe Biden, Joe Biden.
Joe Mama, Joe Mama, Joe Mama.
Oh, thanks.
You're welcome.
I'm gonna sit here and try and get used to stuff, guys.
So now I'm ragdolled.
And then if I press Q again...OK.
Why though?
I press Q right now and it makes me ragdolled.
Oh, but it...OK, that's what it is.
Oh, I get it, I get it, I get it.
OK.
OK, you should be good.
Yeah, if you see him, sprint around the corner and slide under something like low, like a desk or something.
OK, OK.
And then you're usually OK.
I'm following you, Laimo.
OK.
Wait, I hear music.
I hear spooky music.
It's probably no big deal.
OK.
I believe you.
There might be items like up there, but none of us have double jump, though.
Oh, I'll use this magic wand.
OK, there's a delicate cup and a big vase.
I can take the vase.
I'm delicate.
There's a...
A little lady.
There's also this if you would prefer not to take the delicate cup.
What is this?
Oh.
What?
This potion?
Oh, I didn't bring it with me?
OK.
Yeah, we can make a stash of things.
Sorry.
Oh!
It's OK.
Oh, good.
It's very, very delicate.
I break like most of those.
Don't worry about it.
OK, I'm gonna take the ocarina.
You can leave it there until we find the cart, maybe.
OK.
For the extraction.
Gentle.
Yeah.
Talking all over everyone's streams, right?
No, you're good.
I'm sorry.
It was an accident.
OK.
I believe you.
Sorry, it was an accident.
OK, let's double team grandma's ashes.
Grandma's ashes?
Lift it.
It's heavy.
I'm lifting.
It will break.
If it breaks, it's your fault.
OK, I'm already grandma.
How can it be my fault?
You're the ashes?
Yay, good job.
You got this.
We can try to lift the ball in, but...
Mint, you should touch this.
Yeah, you should touch it.
Oh.
Oh my gosh, we're flirting with each other.
Just a little bit.
Text-to-speech flirting.
It's fire here!
Fire!
I love that it's not saying anything about Matara.
You would've been so alive if the skull was right behind us just then.
That would've been so good.
Oh, that would've been silly.
Should I put this in here?
Yeah, it's very delicate.
Be careful with it.
I almost... I tried to grab it.
I almost got it.
Should we start taking it back?
We have to find the next point.
OK.
I don't think this thing is gonna fit in here.
Yeah, let's... I think we should leave the cart here and try to find the next zone.
Oh, they found it!
They found it!
Wow, easy peasy.
Alright, where are you guys?
Hello?
OK, it's this way.
I'm following you.
I'm looking at the map.
OK, I'm moving very delicately.
I'm moving.
It didn't make it like a little hard to see.
Alright, I'm not gonna run into you.
I might run into you.
It will be on accident obviously.
It's like when you... Go hide!
Go hide!
Cinder?
You just balled up right?
You're just a little ball right now, right?
Cinder?
Tora?
Joe Biden was here and killed Cinder!
There's a ducky!
I touched...
We should have warned you about the duck.
Nobody warned me about the duck.
Yeah, don't touch the duck.
I don't... OK.
Limes, can you hear me?
I think the big ball died.
The duck, if you're listening, don't touch him.
Even sometimes if you accidentally touch him, you will die.
Because he turns into angry duck.
I'm gonna put your heads back in.
And I'm gonna see what Limes is up to.
From what I can tell, the duck kind of follows where your cursor is pointing.
And he'll try to jump in front of you.
That's so messed up!
Yeah, that's why it's really hard to resist the urge to pet the duck.
I was trying to yeet him.
I think we can get him killed by the thingy.
Limes, they're both dead.
And I think we looted the place.
Yeah, they got killed by the duck.
Woohoo!
We're the best!
Let me just...
Oh, they found the ball!
Oh, they saved it!
Wait, didn't we find another one?
No, you're right.
That was from the previous thing.
You're right!
They saved it!
How would we do that?
I know.
Dang.
Matara said this game is easy.
Yeah, once you get the hang of it.
Yeah, they're saying that I can bait him to jump...
Oh fuck, there's the alien tree.
To be fair, we both had one health.
Oh, so true!
That's not a bad idea.
Did she just shut the door on him?
Wait, wait, wait.
I wanna kill the duck.
With the way that they told me.
Can I equip myself somewhere that's not...
I think they can bait the duck.
I'm gonna move the duck.
They said I can try to bait him into a cauldron.
Let me just try.
A cauldron!
Is he following you?
Did he start following you?
Yeah, yeah.
He is so cute though.
I want him to follow me.
So they said to bait him to jump in with me.
Little nice ducky bath.
Let go.
He's like, I know what they're up to.
He knew what you were about.
I'm gonna start walking back because I am a coward.
Tax return.
Nice!
Hot dog.
Hanging.
We're gonna be able to buy so much stuff.
I know!
I'm alive!
Hey girls!
Welcome back.
Now we must run.
1 HP and a dream.
I hope there's no old men around here.
Oh great.
I forgot about that entire upper section with the bunk bed.
Oh there's a ducky.
What's an alien?
I'm
alive!
I'm just far away.
But I'm alive.
Oh, hello.
What's that sound?
What?
I...what?
How did it get me?
I didn't touch him!
That was weird.
I pulled you out of his gravity field and he still exploded you.
What bullshit.
No way.
Matara you got this.
She so got this.
She's got this.
Sometimes at random attacks?
No way.
Die.
Sit there.
She gon' die.
Oh, all of our heads.
Yeah, Matara just needs to get back to the ship.
Will we all be revived if she doesn't get all the heads?
We don't get the bonus 25 health, but we get revived with one.
Okay, okay.
I think she should just go.
Oh, there it is.
Yeah, she should be able to get at least one.
At least one person.
Stay here, I'm gonna go save the others.
Unless you wanna come with me.
Up to you.
They're not very far.
Whatever you prefer.
Okay, I'll help you.
Do not put their head into the duct.
If you can.
I'll go for the...oh fuck.
So when the alien just...
Go under the table.
What table?
There's no table.
The table in front where I'm looking.
Oh, I'm leaving.
I didn't see a table.
I'm blind.
He can't come in here, right?
I'm boxing, I'm boxing.
Start the ship!
Wait!
I didn't do it.
That was so good!
Oh my god.
Yeah, I almost killed you.
Start the ship!
I yelled...
I got so screwed over.
Like, I rescued Cinder from the alien...
And then it blew her up anyway.
I was like, okay, whatever.
I go strength.
Okay.
What do I buy?
How much is a gun?
But what if we get a sword?
I have one health.
We have a pan.
Recharge.
And then, once we let the ship go, you just spam E.
I'm gonna let you guys handle all the buying stuff, since I don't know what to do.
I'm just, I'm observing everybody, I'm observing.
If I get a sword, I'm gonna do this with it.
Oh my god, Gray Fox, he's really alive.
Just like you said.
Just like I said, he truly is alive.
Mint, get your butt back in the ship.
Mint, press the envelope.
As the ship is taking off, Cinder just keep spamming E into the loading screen until...
I'm pressing it?
Oh there it is.
I'm spamming, I'm spamming.
Mint, how much health do you have?
26.
Okay, eat this green thing.
And Limes, I think you also have very little stamina, right?
Pick it.
40.
Listen, I may not be able to go for very long, but I'm big.
Don't worry about it.
You're strong and muscular and sexy.
Oh yeah, oh yeah.
Look at those muscles.
What's wrong with E?
So, Limes, people are saying with strength upgrades, you can toss enemies into pits or smash them around.
What enemies could she do that with just two?
What are the enemies that it works with?
Okay, I'm just warning you, Mint.
If you see a grandpa that is blind, he will shoot everything that he hears.
So just duck.
He won't be able to see you.
Okay.
And don't use your mic.
I found an eyeball.
Oh shit, sorry.
Is there a grandpa here?
He just tends to be, I don't know, but he tends to be in this house.
Grandpa's house.
We're looting grandpa's house, so yeah.
It's kind of dank and musty in here.
Yeah, I get that a lot.
There's Minecraft in here.
Girl!
I wanted to be able to pick that up, but it didn't let me.
You're so powerful.
Musty and crusty.
Yeah, I say that to her all the time.
According to Mint.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Dusty.
That's the Matara con.
Dusty, crusty, musty.
I got a thing.
Oh shit.
Sorry.
Hello.
Did you just drop your thing?
No, I'm okay.
I've got it.
Okay.
What Matara didn't tell you is if the shotgun guy does show up, you can't move quickly and you can't use your mic.
He's very sound sensitive.
Okay, okay.
You can't move.
Okay.
She was like, just duh.
Okay, so that's not the only thing.
I know.
I have a cup.
Radioactive.
Hey, Mata.
Mint, your laughter sounds like those children laughing in horror movies to freak people out.
Yeah, yeah.
I was hearing it.
I'm like, oh my God.
I am a ghost after all.
I have to sound a little creepy.
I am spooky scary.
I'm like what people say about me.
Right, guys.
Perfect ghost.
She's scary.
Scary.
What is this?
Is this a fridge?
Uh-oh.
I don't like the music.
What do I do?
What do we have?
Okay, Mint.
If you see a creepy like black shadowy figure with a baby face mask, try not to look at it and try to get underneath something.
Okay.
The baby, there's like two of them.
There's a big one who I think is about getting away from him and then there's like a little baby one who's definitely like don't look at it.
Yeah, there's a tall one.
So don't look at the baby.
Get under the table and don't look at the baby.
How
the fuck did you not die?
How did you die?
Oh, yeah.
And I stole that health upgrade.
It was for a hundred health.
And he shoot for a hundred health.
And now I just have one.
You can only...
You can only play this game on one HP, Cinder.
You're playing on hard mode.
She's gonna get shot.
Are we safe?
We're never really safe, are we?
I don't know how we're gonna get that clock out with grandpa patrolling.
I'll tank one bullet, you think I can tank another one?
I don't think so.
I think yeah.
I like how you just stand there.
Cinder's so brave.
Alright, let's go.
He went down the hallway straight down there.
So I think we might be able to grab the clock.
Easy, careful.
Easy does it.
Careful.
Oh my god.
Are you kidding me?
I'm the old man, guys.
How'd they do that?
Oh, that was you.
I thought the grandpa killed me.
Well, it did feel like I was getting shot.
Okay, we haven't gone in here.
Spooky attic.
I think he's upstairs.
I don't think he went up there.
Hold on, there's something here.
Cash money?
Oh, it's only $600.
Look at her.
She thinks she's better than $600.
I mean, I grabbed two balls worth thousands of dollars.
Yeah, my breasts.
Sorry, that was not my greatest joke I've ever made.
No.
But it will be funny if I ever do get my breasts.
At least you feel, oh, I missed the ball.
Oh my gosh, how did I miss that?
Yeah, you gotta like go up.
Always try to like go up and look around.
Oh, you gotta go up where?
Like, for example, look here.
See, there's also like here.
You gotta open every door.
I missed that.
Oh, I didn't see this.
Oh my gosh.
It's because you're small.
You didn't think to jump.
You're not used to looking up at things.
That's actually true.
Gamers don't look up.
I felt very cute when you were like, can you get me that cup?
I'm like, yeah, I got you, poopy.
I got you, baby.
Let's leave the car here.
And then let's explore because that way we'll have an easier exploration.
He normally goes down this hallway.
How do you know?
Because I've watched his movements.
I'm a grandpa observer.
Hello.
Goodbye.
It was nice knowing you.
Yeah, see you later.
When you say goodbye and then you end up going in the same direction.
Well, the door just shut.
I don't know why.
I found the next extract point.
Oh, nice.
She's gaming.
Also the fridge, you can open it.
Yeah, I did it earlier.
And the freezer.
I know you're short, but yeah.
I got it, I got it.
I know...
Everything.
Big item.
Yeah, you do.
What?
What's rough?
What's wrong?
Oh, we got this.
I'm searching everywhere, guys.
There's like nothing here.
There's nothing there.
Does this go to the bathroom?
Is this a looping point?
Yes, it is.
Yeah.
I'm here.
So, Steve, for example, there's this item, right?
There's no point bringing it all the way back to the cart.
But we can just bring it to the next extraction point.
Right.
Which is very close.
And then once we get the next...
So, come here, come here.
It's gonna be down these stairs.
I'm moving.
She's moving.
So, it's gonna be down these stairs.
And then as soon as we do...
If you look up top right, it says 7500 on 15000.
Yeah.
And then as soon as we finish one extraction point, we press this one.
Okay.
With the harder levels, it's sometimes nice to leave one of the points that's sort of next to the exit.
So that we have an easier time running back.
Because all the monsters respawn.
I didn't realize you could choose which extraction point to start with.
Oh.
So, for example, there's something to be said about not picking the third one as our last lap.
Ah, yeah.
You've got a game here.
Ah!
Yeah, I'm alive.
I'm alive, but...
I think we can grab him.
Try pressing him to see if we can grab him.
Okay, wait.
I don't think we can grab him just the two of us.
Maybe we can.
That's them doing one of the thingies.
Let's wait for them.
Yeah.
We're trapped here!
I think for the spider, we need to be both of us.
Let me talk to Lime about...
Leaving this one maybe for the last extraction.
Otherwise, we will die.
We will die.
What the heck?
Where did that come from?
There's also the no face.
Right?
It was on top.
That's why you gotta look on top of the shelf, Spooky.
What the...
Okay.
I wish there was like a scanner.
She just dodged.
I wish I could jinx her.
I wish I could sabotage her.
That guy came out of nowhere!
He came out of nowhere!
I think I will probably die every single round of this game.
Where is Lime hiding from?
Where is everybody hiding from?
Everybody is hiding from something!
Everybody is around the grandpa.
A body is up there.
She said dumb?
The speeder!
My head is stuck.
Wait, my head is actually stuck.
Guys, you can't help it.
I'm just too big brained.
Big head.
Everybody make fun of Minko with a huge head.
You'll get the hang of it.
Yeah, this is my first time playing ever, ever, ever.
Sorry guys, if I'm a little stinky.
Big noggin.
Are you guys having fun?
Are you guys...
Lime!
Oh, hi!
So Lime, there's an extraction point down here.
But I think we should keep it until the end.
Because there's grandpa, there's no face, there's spider, there's so many people.
Let's keep that one then.
Yeah, but I mean, let's try to keep this closer point for the last point.
That way we have an easier way back.
I'll try to find it.
I'll try to find the other one right now.
What do you want me to say in the chat?
What do you want me to say?
Okay, good, good, good.
Don't press this button.
But we can grab Minko's head because we're going to bring her to the next extraction.
I know, right?
They're Tokyo.
I was worried about you.
She's so cute.
There's also a really big heart.
Limes, since you have strength...
Since you have strength Limes, you can try bringing the heart while I look for the next extraction point.
The heart is right here.
Was that grandpa?
Something else just appeared.
Oh, that was Matara.
It was the grandma, not the grandpa.
This guy is so silent.
Oh my gosh.
She's hiding in the fridge.
What does she think she is?
A snack?
What was this?
No,
she's a whole meal.
She's the appetizer.
She's the main course.
She's the dessert.
She's the palate cleanser.
I feel so old when I hear that.
I don't even know what that is.
What is that?
I know what a roflcopter is.
Everyone is so quiet.
It's easy for me to talk.
Look at my eyeballs.
They look like boba.
Yummy.
Microsoft Sam.
You get the real, true POV here, guys.
You get every POV from Mito.
She uses her map so much.
She holds it so close to her face.
Can't read.
Nice.
Real ghost POV.
I'm haunting everybody.
I gotta look up more.
I really don't look up much.
And that's actually true.
If I'm hanging out with friends, I just don't look up.
Maybe that's rude when I'm talking to them.
I don't wanna hurt my neck.
Gamers never look up.
It's true.
Real gamers don't look up.
That's what I'm saying.
I'm a gamer.
So you stare at her.
I'm in hell.
Source?
I would know.
Look at him.
Little guy.
Looks just like you, Matara.
You know what they say about big boobs.
Big nose.
And big feet.
Why is she still talking about me?
Why are you so obsessed with me?
Do we have fart time?
Wait, I wonder what it says.
Wait, why is she...what's there?
Oh my shit.
Sorry.
I thought...I think I just saw Matara getting killed.
We might have done that a little too soon.
It should be fine.
The cart has another 10k or 7k in it or something.
We put this in the cart.
We wheel the cart to the other extraction point and we're good.
The spider just ran past.
If he comes in here...
If the big spider thing comes in here, we're all gonna want to hold him.
No, we grab him.
Grab him, lift him up and down.
I'll try and count for timing.
And if we do it right, we slam him and he dies.
Motherfucker.
I don't know where we are, so I'll trust in her.
I need the cart, because there is...
She's alive!
Spider's here.
The extraction point's done.
We need the other one now.
Spider?
Sorry.
There's also a little wad of money.
And there's the doll earning.
But I don't think we should do it, because she makes a sound.
Unless we have the cart right here.
No, I need to go... I can go get the cart.
Where are we?
Okay, that was BS.
That was BS.
That was so bull.
How did Lime live?
He came in real.
I'm dead.
There's no coming around.
We probably would've been fine if we didn't...
That's so unfortunate.
You got this, Matoro!
Oh, she's being sneaky.
Lime.
Lime is both being sneaky.
A man and his dog spider.
Get him, boy!
We need to old yeller this spider.
I was so ready to grab him too.
Yeah, I tried.
I was like, oh, I'm gonna grab him and I died immediately.
I was like, okay, Lime, one, two.
They're whispering.
They got this.
They just have to do one more.
Yeah, and then get back.
Yeah, oh yeah, I forgot about that part.
I've never seen this many monsters in one level.
Really?
I don't think I ever got this far.
Dang, there's three extraction points instead of just two this time?
We're getting fancy.
I know.
Wait, there's only two monsters, right?
There's the old guy and the spider, but then there's also...
It's like a baby.
It sounds like a baby.
It's like a kid laughing.
I didn't see the baby.
It's like a tall, shadowy figure.
And if you look at it, it'll get you.
Oh, that's right.
I think there's usually two of them that spawn together, so...
It's like, you count them all up and it's a lot.
It is a lot.
Martha almost got blasted again.
Did she?
Yeah, the bookcase was in the way.
Lucky.
Lucky ducky.
Where's the last extraction point?
The guy is coming up the stairs behind her.
I just saw him walk up the stairs.
He's in the hallway behind her!
Oh my god.
It's her!
Oh no!
It's a good thing he swore.
I know, right?
She doesn't know.
Do you want to be greedy with it?
Greedy!
There's two dead people!
We should get their heads.
He fell down the stairs!
Grandpa fell down the stairs!
Grandpa!
That's why you need to use your cave instead of the gun!
He just walked back up though.
Wow.
They got so lucky!
Right?
I mean in theory we could keep luring him down here and he'd keep falling down those flushing stairs.
And what do you want to do?
Do you want to just load this in and finish it up?
They just need to keep talking and he'll keep falling down the stairs.
Holy shit, we need to repeatedly bait him into falling down the stairs.
It's like those video compilations where people are just like...
It is!
He's going to fall down again.
Well that was my point.
Do we want to just go back to the ship and just deal with them being at one health?
Because getting their heads and coming back with him camping that whole way is going to be hard.
You can start going to the ship if you want and I'll wait like five minutes.
I'll wait like two minutes and I'll put it in.
Okay?
Goodness me.
You have two minutes girl, get excited!
Okay.
Oh gosh.
She's still laughing down there.
I don't know how I stayed quiet throughout that.
Oh my goodness.
I know.
I would mute my mic.
I would have to mute my mic.
That was so good.
Grandpa.
Come on grandpa, let's get you to bed.
Oops, fell down again.
My hip!
My other hip!
Where did these stairs get here?
I bet he didn't see that one coming.
Oh yeah, take him down!
Dad!
I love how Matz is just standing in the corner.
Is that what she's doing?
Oh my god.
Matar...
She's counting.
It's really hard for her.
She's got to concentrate.
She's got to focus.
Yeah, she's really got to focus.
What comes after...
Can only count...
Where is Limel hiding from?
How how?
I
can't see.
I can't tell where she's hiding from.
Maybe just to be safe.
What's the plan?
I actually don't know what's going on.
So, I'm sent up to the ship.
And...
Matara is getting the last...
What's that sound?
Because when...
Oh!
That was the extraction.
Oh, okay, okay.
Yeah, when you get the last one, the monster is kind of...
They aggro, right?
A little more aggressive.
Okay, I'm so scared.
I'm sorry I was being quiet.
Valid.
It's so dark.
It's funny how she's like almost always yapping and now she just...
I know.
Her character model looks so scary.
Pardon my language.
Oh my gosh, how are you supposed to see?
Oh my god, he's right there.
The way he uses his gun as a cane is crazy.
Right?
I'm taking notes.
Like a metal grandpa.
Alright, you got this, Matara.
Oh no!
She dodged the bullet!
She literally dodged the bullet!
What?
Oh my god.
She...
Oh my god, the moves.
Okay, she's popping off.
Yeah.
Where's the baby?
What's it hearing?
Probably the little spider guy.
Matara, choose the rest of the monsters for me.
Friendly fire?
Come on.
Limes is leaving!
No way!
She probably thinks Mata is dead by now.
I should've stayed on the ship!
Wait, I'm right here!
Oh my god, I had the grandpa and then the spider ran in.
We saw you juke that thing!
That was crazy!
You gave!
64,000 money!
Money!
The spider chased me back to the ship and I kind of had to throw him into a corner and continue running.
What's the dice?
I opt for strength.
I think with one more strength I can actually toss him up and down by myself, so I want that.
Yeah!
Grab it!
I'm gonna spin him around.
You spin me right round.
Right round.
The noise cancellation.
Do you want to cheat?
Do you want to steal?
How do I cheat?
Okay, grab this to the ship and then Sam E when the ship leaves.
Okay.
I hit you so hard I hit myself.
Let's turn this trusty frying pan...
into a drying pan!
Did you girls see us continuously make grandpa fall down the stairs?
Yes!
It was so good!
I didn't even know he would go down those ones.
I just heard like, who's happy?
Do you think they'll patch this cheat out?
Oh yeah, for sure.
Oh.
We stealing.
Alright, we good.
So, E?
E, E, E, E, yep.
Limes, are you also stealing health?
I can E if you want.
I wasn't going to because I'm fairly healthy.
Okay.
Get it.
I'm spamming, I'm spamming.
Spamming, spamming, spamming, spamming, spamming, spamming, spamming.
When do I stop?
Keep going, keep going.
Okay.
You should be good.
Stinder, Mint, you guys have a health and a stamina.
Pick one, which one do you want?
How much stamina do you have?
Fifty.
Can it take forever?
I love it.
So do I.
How much health do you have?
Like your max health.
One forty.
I've got one.
Holy moly.
Okay.
I have a hundred.
You guys are so healthy.
Wait, wait, Mint, Mint, Mint, hold on.
Okay.
Too late.
It's okay, it's okay, don't worry about it.
No, no, it's fine.
I'll do a health upgrade next time.
I've just been so strong.
My bad.
No, no, don't worry about it.
I'm a speedy, I'm a speed demon.
Yeah.
So when's the gun show start?
We haven't got it.
So, unfortunately with this game, you kind of have to like also get like the guns and items.
For you girl, anytime.
No, I meant, I meant...
You have to get what?
All her sexy guns.
Oh, what was that?
That's the extraction.
Anytime, anytime you want it, I'm here.
Man, I'm pretty.
Look, Mint, it's your trophy.
It says number one loser.
Haha.
You're dumb, you're dumb.
I think, I think it's yours because you read it first.
Who smelled it dealt it.
Idiot, idiot, idiot, idiot, loser, loser, loser.
L, L, L, L, stinky.
L, L, L.
Stupid cockroach.
L, L, L, cockroach, cockroach.
Everybody is like, oh my god, she's going to heaven.
I'm like, have you guys met your Oshi?
She is, the fact that she is here proves we are in purgatory.
I think that's true.
Yeah, I don't think they...
Oh, hello.
There's also something right there.
Pardon.
What are these?
Oh, there's also grandma's ashes.
What is this?
A doll.
Oh, it is a doll.
Oh, it's cute.
Creepy doll.
Oh, yeah, creepy doll.
Hello.
A vase.
Yeah, grandma's ashes and big cube.
Oh, there's stuff here too.
Actually, you might...
Oh my god, is there a strong sexy 4'11 woman?
Me?
Strong sexy 4'11 woman.
Stop, why are you so obsessed with me?
You're not sexy or strong.
I'll carry this right back to spawn.
I got a diamond.
Oh!
Me!
She was targeted!
I saw that!
You saw!
You're my witness in court, Cinder!
You're my witness in court!
Oh my god, so you're saying I'm smart and I have a big head?
Uh-oh, there's something in here.
I can carry the card, by the way.
It's purple.
Careful.
It makes me sound like I'm actually having an asthma attack when I say your name.
Something just took her away, finally.
Yeah, I don't know what just happened.
Something like dragged her into the darkness.
She's probably fine.
There was one more room back here that I wanted to pick up.
And then we can bring stuff back.
I like the locations.
Oh my god.
Lagooner's here.
There's an invisible Gooner.
He runs along invisible going plop, plop, plop and then he grabs you and takes you to a different part of the map.
That's what he did to Matara!
She got gooned!
Lagooner got her.
I like the crackhead wizard here.
I know, I like this guy.
You think that's a dev or...?
I think so.
Sorry for calling you a crackhead, devs.
So is she alive or...?
She'll have been like dragged off to some other part of the castle.
Lagooner didn't kill me the last time he kidnapped me, so maybe she's fine.
She's fine.
Yeah, just like I said.
Yeah, exactly.
How would you do to avoid him?
I guess run away yelling Gooner because it worked for me.
You just shame him dude.
Easy.
Bro's like, that ain't me.
I...
I ain't no tier 3 sub.
What's that sound?
I thought that thud was the...
Cast some spell!
Make me taller!
Ok, so I can't make you taller, but I can make you much, much shorter.
I'm gonna take this back to the thing.
Why don't we use this again?
Oh, something just...
Something's around here.
It's a new one in the box!
This is a collector's item!
This is fancy.
Oh, this looks like a broomstick.
It's the speed demon!
We should...
Yeah, let's take it.
Ten thousand!
Oh, it's heavy.
Oh, we should find the next point to bring it to actually.
Yeah.
Or, or we could take it to the one we just found.
Yeah, I think so too.
I think we could take it there.
And then we could save it earlier.
It's close.
Yeah.
Ten thousand.
Oh, you got it?
Ok, we got it?
We're good.
Yeah, we're good, we're good.
We got this.
Nice and easy.
Yeah, yeah.
It's this way and then to the right.
Oh yeah, that's right.
I am so bad with directions.
I got you.
Oh, there we go.
You were right.
Yeah.
Oh, this way.
Whichever.
It's like there's two sides.
We're both going up different ways.
I'm lifted.
Up the stairs.
Ok.
We're so close.
And...
On the ground?
Yeah, we could just put it...
Oh, oh, me on the ground.
Just kidding.
That was so good.
I thought we might have at least bonked it a little bit on the way up here.
No.
Oh, hello.
We found a really giant room.
Oh, that's cool.
It's $10,000.
That's a lot of dollars.
Did we want to leave?
Oh, that's a plant.
We need to find Matara and pop like her head with all the loot that we got.
Because we have like loads back at the base.
You think she's dead?
Ok, guys.
No, she's right here.
I got snatched!
And then he brought me in a room with this theater guy and there's the big, the big one-eyed guy that like...
But there's so much treasure.
I'm just gonna call it the first extraction point.
There's a one-eyed what?
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
Lime, lime, lime, lime, lime.
Wait, wait, wait, wait.
Lime!
The way she zoomed into frame was so funny.
No one...
saw that.
Ok, never mind.
No one saw that.
Yeah.
You literally just got dragged away.
It was so funny.
Really?
Like a new experience for you?
Can I jump on top of this?
I don't think that's... Oops.
I don't think that's true.
Okay.
So you want the gooner.
Yeah, she wants the gooner.
Oh, you do?
Okay.
There's another thing up there too.
What was that sound?
Oh!
Selling stuff.
Yeah!
Oh, they are selling stuff.
What's happening?
Oh, this is the thing that slows you down.
I'm going really slowly.
Blah, blah, blah.
Mataracon stinks!
What just happened?
I'm coming!
There we go.
Nice and easy.
Yep.
Okay.
What did I say?
I'm good!
Something is chasing after me too.
There's like a million things in here.
What is going on?
There's like a million things...
I can use this to attack too maybe.
What is that?
Oops.
That's fine.
It's still worth money.
Again?
Hello!
I'm back!
Hi!
Bye-bye!
I'm alive!
I'm getting goons again!
Help me!
Thank you!
Oh, gross!
Wait, what is that thing?
Is that not it?
Oh, it's gone.
Actually, now I have... I knew where I was before and now I have no idea!
Is this where the ship is?
I knew where I was before!
Now I have no idea.
It's time for the map.
Oh, is that what the ship looks like?
I think this is the ship, no?
Yeah!
Just a little sip for the road.
Wait, sorry, I just turned around.
He just drags you wherever he pleases.
He kind of saved me from that guy.
I'm not going to lie.
OK Hello!
Hello!
A weird tour guide.
I thought you were saying hi to me.
He can't hear me, right?
Babe!
Hey, stupid!
Stupid!
He's an ogre.
Yeah, that guy is really, really strong and he will definitely do some serious damage.
Hey, can a couple of people come and help me lift the box up the stairs?
I cannot do that one by myself.
At least he's slow, right?
OK We cannot let this one tip over, otherwise it starts taking tons of damage.
So we gotta be careful.
I wouldn't know that.
Oh, sorry.
I'm coming back!
Oh, you got it, you got it, you got it.
OK Oh no, the money bag!
We're fine, we're fine.
I think we pop this extraction point now.
Because, like, that's a lot.
OK Box first, maybe, and then broom.
Box, then broom, then bag.
OK I'll move this out of the way.
Oh, thank you.
Shall we... Oh, so box first, then broom, then bag.
OK.
You got it, you got it.
You got it.
Easy.
Hell yeah.
Bag.
Alright.
Oh, watch out!
Get out of there!
Oh, I was worried about it.
That sucks.
Wait, what happened?
The box broke, but we still got the broom.
Yeah, the box broke.
I was trying to pull out the broom brick.
Oh, that sucks.
Wait, we still got the money for it?
Wait, we have...
We got... We got some of it.
Eww!
Give me a hug!
No, no, don't get near her!
Eww!
Get away from me, you freak!
Stop throwing up on me, please!
It's not funny.
I don't love you out there.
Wait, what is that thing?
Is that not the gooner?
Avoid him.
It is.
Avoid him, avoid him, avoid him.
That's not the gooner.
The gooner is...
Grab something small, we can smack him.
Oh, uh...
We've sold everything.
No, no, no.
I smacked him with the door before.
Oh, okay.
He's behind you!
Okay, you're good.
You're good.
I could've slobbered all over you.
It just makes your tummy hurt.
An apology for fucking that up.
I'm bringing the rest of the stuff.
Ah...
Oh, I see.
It didn't go through all the way.
That sucks.
No, the box got smooshed because the broom was out.
And I was worried that the broom wouldn't count.
And then trying to move the broom in, the box went out.
It's okay.
Oh, Matara's Parasite is free.
What are we careful about?
Matara's Parasite is flying around in there now.
Guys, guys, guys, guys.
If I smack him with the door...
If I smack him with the door, we can grab him and then kill him.
Hold on, I'm...
That's a weird looking door.
When the Parasite gives you silly girl syndrome.
Make your tummy hurt.
I wanna be a silly girl.
Get him!
No!
Oh, you can already grab him.
It's because you're so strong.
Yeah, you got him.
Woah, what's the eyeball do?
It's loot.
Question though, wait, wait, wait, wait.
Why did we keep this one for last?
Because it's close to the base.
No, it's already popped.
Have we found the third one?
I'm following.
Beep, beep, beep, beep, beep.
Beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep.
You know.
What?
You wouldn't know.
You're not a maid.
It's very special.
I have to preserve it.
I have to preserve it for really intense cases.
For real troubles.
She can't hear me.
I have to save it for you guys.
Hehehe.
Not gonna waste it on her.
Find the next extraction point.
Maybe I went past it.
There's like, oh.
Wait, who is that?
Oh.
Me.
It's cuffing season.
What?
Mind careful, there's a big boy here.
Oh, the walking man?
Yeah, the slow walking man.
Yeah.
He's scary.
Does he get fast?
When he sees you?
No.
But he can pull you aside.
Oh, okay.
Oh!
What?
Matara?
We need to pop the button when we see it.
Yeah, I was...
I got dragged into here earlier.
Yeah, me too, me too.
There's grandma's ashes.
Oh, is that what that is?
Oh, yeah.
So now if you have items here, you can just put them there.
Oh, okay.
You can already put this item into...
Oh, we can get grandma's ashes.
Just try to put them all in like one side.
Careful.
Careful, behind you, behind you, behind you.
Oh, oh, oh.
Try to put them all in like one side, so that way we can put the garden to the other side.
Okay, okay, okay.
Strategic strategy.
And always try to open doors through their forest.
Okay.
Careful.
You wanna help me?
I need your help with grandma!
We're both going down.
No, there can only be one.
No!
My grandma is better.
Wait, I just saw you lose a bunch of money.
What did you do?
Oh, shit.
Did you dump her all over the ground?
Maybe.
Yeah.
So don't dump...
Oh!
I just saw you...
My grandma is still worth more.
Your grandma is pretty cool.
She's worth more.
Okay, well...
That's a little...
Racist, I guess?
How?
Excuse me?
How dare you say your elderly female relative is worth a lot?
She is worth a lot, you know?
Is there something here too?
Wanna grab this?
I'll bring the cube and the other stuff.
Yeah, I'm grabbing this thingy.
I saw it earlier.
Sometimes it like flags things randomly.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, we really lost a lot.
Yeah, unfortunately we lost a lot.
So sometimes, when you lose too much money...
You basically then have to start killing the monsters.
Otherwise, you just won't make it.
There's also something up here if you wanna grab it.
I thought I saw something light up here.
Yeah, up there.
If you ever look at your tab, it's gonna tell you roughly where it is.
You can always find it again.
Oh, I see.
How do I get the thing up there?
You jump up a little bit.
Is it that thing right there?
Wait, which one?
It's like a little clock up there.
Oh, oh, oops.
Do you see it?
This thing?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
You get better at recognizing things.
I know right now it's kind of like, wow, how do I know that?
But don't you just like check everything?
You said it's a clock.
It's an ocarina.
Oh, is it?
It looked like a clock.
Yellow dots.
Oh, someone's coming.
Who's that someone?
I don't know.
Is it the girls or is it a bad someone?
They're blue.
Oh, blue is our cart.
Oh.
Yellow is the other players.
Blue is a cart.
And then sometimes you'll see red.
Oh, there they are.
Hello.
Hi.
I think yellow is loot.
Yeah, yellow is loot.
And red is like their face.
So you can see if somebody's alive if they move their face.
So you can be like, oh, they're alive.
All right, can one of you grab this?
I cannot jump onto this bed.
Hold on.
This picture is awesome.
You good?
Oh, you guys scared me.
I see it.
There's a trap door here.
Oh my gosh.
Is there anything in here?
Now I know that...
Okay, you do the bed.
Where's the bed?
What am I doing?
Can you climb up there?
I gotta get used to it.
You're back!
I was so scared for you.
He brought me back right to where I was.
Oh, I see, I see.
Oh, oh, oh!
I almost had it.
Wait.
Everybody's alive!
All right, there's a hourglass.
Hold on.
If you want to grab it.
I'll give it to you to grab.
Oh, never mind.
You can try doing it.
Right there.
I can grab it?
Yeah.
Wait.
I got it.
Move back a little bit.
Yeah, yeah.
I got it.
Wait.
She got it.
I'm trying to slowly...
All right, there we go.
If you jump off, will you fall in slow motion too?
Oh, let's try it.
Let's try it.
But make sure you keep the hourglass up.
Keep it up.
Higher than you.
Okay.
Oh, don't hit the ceiling!
Here I go!
All right.
Yay!
Amazing.
Where are you guys?
She descended like a spirit.
Behind you, behind you, behind you.
Okay, I'm turning.
Wait, wait, bring the cart to her.
Oh, yeah, she's...
I'm turning slowly.
The mint on the hourglass sounds really stoned.
I mean, look at her eyes.
I'm...
I...
I eat cookies.
Wait, where's the cart?
She got into the silly brownies.
Where's the cart?
You're doing amazing, sweetie.
Just keep going straight.
Oh, okay.
Keep going straight.
Keep going straight, girl.
You got it.
Okay.
I'm going.
Mint, who's your favorite viewer?
Try it.
Viewer?
I don't have one.
I love everyone equally.
I think she's trying to get you to say Mataracon.
No, I don't watch her.
I don't watch her.
Hello, Mito.
Live.
You sound like Freddy Fazbear when you laugh.
Hey, everybody, and welcome to the YouTube channel.
Mataracon Double D's Soul Threat.
What?
You've never heard of Dave Albor, you bitch?
I think we have.
What?
Oh no, the QBA app.
I think the Q is fine.
There we go.
It's good, it's good, it's good.
Matara!
You're alive!
Welcome back.
How did you live?
Oh, run?
Yeah, we're going.
Save your energy until you see someone.
Because then...
Look out for the big daddy.
I mean like run in spirit.
Don't actually run.
Oh yeah, yeah.
Running in spirit.
Go in her!
I'm getting dragged towards the entrance.
Let's go!
Thanks Gooner.
Oh my gosh, wait.
I'm actually getting dragged towards the entrance.
I'm cheating.
Thank you.
I heard him huffing and puffing, but I didn't let him get me.
Now leave them.
They have 30 seconds before I start the countdown.
It was a wisp.
Thank you guys.
What do I do?
Gosh, I had the easy way, huh?
They have to get past the big guy.
I had it so easy.
My guy literally ran right past me.
Made me run right past him.
It was awesome.
I didn't have to do anything.
Mito wins by doing nothing!
I should hide still just in case.
Imagine if he comes and grabs me again.
That would suck so bad.
Can you check the map?
Can I zoom out?
I can't.
What's the red thing?
Is that the extractor?
Wait, what's the red thing?
What is that?
Oh, it is an extraction.
They're slow.
No, I ran past the giant guy.
They have to be careful around him or they'll die.
That's where you extract stuff.
I don't remember that one.
I only remember...
The one up the stairs.
Actually, I guess this was the first one.
Maybe they're dead?
No, they're not dead.
They're alive.
They're alive, I believe, I believe, I believe.
I can't see anything about them though.
I'm wiggling so I can...
Wishful thinking?
No, they're alive.
They're alive for sure.
How long should I wait though?
How long?
Maybe they'll get got by the gooner and they'll also run all the way here.
He'll be a kind, gentle soul to them as well.
Five more minutes, okay.
I wonder if I should go to the bathroom.
Bathroom.
Hurry up guys, hurry up.
Hurry up everybody.
It's so hard being me, I'm bored.
Nothing yet?
I want to have faith that they'll make it.
Watch they're all dead right now talking in the chat.
Being like, Minto, please press the button.
Nah, they're alive.
What's that sound?
I think I'm going to press the button.
What was that sound?
Oh, I'm here!
I got gooned, but he dragged me all the way here.
That was nice of him.
I know, I think he's a fan.
Wait, I didn't see you on the map, that's so weird.
You can't actually see your friends on the map, because otherwise it would spoil whether or not they're alive.
Yeah, the yellow dots there are like loot.
Are we just going to wait for Matara then?
She said go without me, I didn't hear if she said I'm not going to run back or if she said I'll run back.
That's like two very mixed messages, we could give her a couple of minutes and if she doesn't show up...
What about Cinder?
Cinder we lost like right at the start.
Apparently someone spoiled it for Matara what happened to her, so that person got timed out.
I don't know what happened to her.
Cinder, if you can hear us...
Hey girl, hey.
I miss my Nations of the World soulmate.
We sang together, it was beautiful.
Sounds lovely.
It was.
Alright.
I mean the thing is if she gets stuck behind the big guy again, it's going to be forever.
And if the gooner runs in, one of us is getting dragged out.
Let's do a pact, if the gooner comes in and drags one of us out, the other person just takes off in the ship.
Because that's bullshit.
Yeah.
Okay.
I sure hope he doesn't get me.
Have you got gooned yet?
No, I keep sliding under furniture every time he tries.
Then it's your turn, honestly.
I don't wanna.
I think, you know, Matara is...
She's a bit slow.
I think we could just go, no?
We can go as long as you tell her it was your fault.
Oh yeah, I'm totally fine with that.
No, she was alive!
She was alive!
Oh god, Matara!
Matara!
Bye Matara!
She'll make it, she'll make it.
I didn't want for this.
She'll totally have that.
Wait, I think I just heard her.
Did I just hear her yell?
No.
She's got 10 seconds.
10...
Oh, 9...
8...
She's so needy.
She's sending us all these texts.
Remember like the AOL notification sound?
Just that over and over again.
OK, we're breaking it up.
Bye Matara!
Jake, please don't.
Matara was like monologuing.
Like three times.
Wait, are you serious?
He kept dragging you back?
While I was in the little hallway to the ship, he kept dragging me back.
At one point I was like, please mom, you can hear me telepathically, end it all.
And she was self-destructive.
She was self-destructive.
I put you out of your misery.
I saw like a lower level and I was like, oh what's down here?
So I jumped down and it was a spike pit.
You honestly had a fucking horror movie death then.
You legitimately, like you were right behind us.
We turned around and we were like, where's Dender?
You just vanished like it was a horror movie.
Should we get any weapons?
What do you think?
There's the sledgehammer.
I just don't know.
Sledgehammer would be good.
Oh, the sledgehammer!
Sledgehammer is more for breaking locks though rather than actual assault.
Yeah, I wanna get more money though.
I bought a health upgrade and a strength upgrade and I got a strength upgrade for someone else too.
I won't eat both, I promise.
I definitely want one of them.
Please.
Okay.
I'm stealing health, I'm sorry.
Me too.
It went from 120 health to 1 and I'm kinda salty about it.
We're playing this for people.
We're teaching how to play.
There are many shit boost items in here.
I think this would be great for attacking.
You don't have to bring it back, but yeah.
Who got me?
You got you.
I got myself?
The Booner thing was BS.
I don't think it was BS, it's just that I didn't understand how it works.
I thought that if I just stayed quiet he wouldn't snatch me, but I was supposed to hide.
As soon as you see him, I just dart for cover and it seems to work quite well.
He dragged me to the entrance.
I don't know why he hates you.
I think he just drags you to the complete opposite end of where you are.
So in your case, he caught you early.
Alright, did it work?
We forgot to buy!
Nobody hit the button.
It's not my responsibility.
I thought we liked shopping.
I thought we were women who shop.
What happened?
I think I started scanning E a little too late.
We can just...
What a bust.
Let me hold you by the neck next time.
I wanna hold her neck.
Stop holding her neck.
Hold on, can we also hold Cinder's neck?
Wait, how do I do it?
I wanna hold her neck.
I've got 70!
I've got 90!
Is that okay on health?
Yeah!
Yeah, I'm good.
I have 69 health now, so I'm okay with this.
I have 90 cynics!
Oh my gosh, we're opposites.
Hold on, y'all.
I gotta thank our Ray.
Hi, Ray!
Hello!
Hiya!
What the fuck is that?
Oh, there's a block.
I don't like that.
Do you see that?
I've not seen that before.
Is that a blob of meat?
Oh!
Hello!
Blob of meat?
It's breathing.
I think it's like a cat.
What if I touch it?
Matara, shut up!
Hello!
Have you messed with it yet?
I'm trying to touch it, but it's not touching.
I think it's just a giant pomegranate.
It's pulsating, though.
I don't like that.
Have you, like, actually touched it?
Yeah, I'm trying to touch it.
I'm on top of it.
Oh, that's weird.
The fuck?
I think we'll hate this thing later, probably.
Yeah.
I kinda wanted to, like, throw Matara into it, but I didn't manage to grab her before she got up.
Oh, here's the extraction point!
That's gonna be really annoying.
Oh, is it supposed to annoy the shit out of us when we're trying to get stuff here?
Probably.
I really hate that.
Oh, that's so evil!
A breathing pomegranate.
There's a first for everything.
What's that sound?
What's here?
I'm scared.
Matara found something.
Oh, you destroyed it?
You're so strong.
Wait, Matara's dead?
I'm screaming.
Oh no, you're fine.
We have to be careful.
There's an eye and a frog chef and a bunch of, like, the little exploding skull.
But the eye grabbed me and then I saw the frog chef.
Throw the exploding skulls at them.
It will be funny.
What do all those things do?
The exploding skulls explode.
But once they start exploding, I think you can throw them back and, like, run back.
Again?
The eye, if it catches you... So, if it catches you, you have to, like, break down and throw it behind a door.
And, um...
The frog chef will run at you with knives.
So, wait, wait, wait.
Cinder, can you help me put this in the car?
Oh, what's that?
Oh, I can't get under the...
Oh, I think I'm dead.
What's up?
Do you want to put the TV in?
Oh, fuck.
Not if you slap me with a, like, a gramophone or whatever.
Sorry.
What?
Oh, that was one of the things exploding.
It set me on fire.
There's a lot of stuff over there, Lime.
Be careful.
OK.
That wasn't for me.
Right?
I kind of ran to, like, a dead end.
Hmm.
So, um, I can't go pretty much anywhere.
Is anyone alive?
I don't know.
I think I heard Godzilla outside.
Yeah, me too.
Oh, shit.
That one's the break line of sight, right?
Yeah.
What was screaming?
I don't know.
Did you hear that?
Yeah, it sounded like Godzilla.
Yeah.
It was, like, screaming over and over again.
So, a little bit further ahead, there's, like, a scary...
A what?
It's, like, a... There's, like, a tombstone.
Oh, fun.
Yeah.
It was, like, freaking scary.
Oh, they're selling their stuff.
That's why I was out there when I was hearing, like, the screams.
I know.
I was just chilling.
I thought I was being haunted.
Not me.
Maybe I am right now.
Lime, Mata, are you guys okay?
Mata's dead.
Oopsie.
We were hiding on the same shelf and it kind of, like, started walking past us and she panicked and jumped down and just got chased and died.
What?
Why did she... Why...
It's kind of scary.
Yeah, we broke some stuff trying to run away.
It's okay.
Yeah, he actually...
He... He stood by the cart and broke a bunch of shit by charging into it over and over again.
There's a lot of good stuff or... There's some stuff in here.
I don't think we've been in...
Okay.
Oh, there's something back here.
Behind the door.
Careful, careful, careful, careful, careful.
Yay.
I kind of remember if you're not supposed to look at that one.
I never look at him just in case.
I know the other one you definitely can't look at.
Whoa.
Okay.
Ritual.
Oh, I'm outside.
Monkey.
It's so spooky out here.
Yeah.
Oh, there's more over here.
Tombstone.
Oh, wait.
This looks like...
The thing that chased... That looks like grandpa.
There's more over here?
Oh, nice.
It's actually kind of peaceful.
It is.
It feels nice out here.
Like, I'll never get hurt.
Whoa.
Yeah.
Traveling into the unknown.
By myself.
And there's a whole...
Lot of nothing.
Maybe?
There's a whole lot of nothing.
I traveled here and it's literally...
A dead end.
You guys didn't see anything, right?
Grandpa died from falling down the stairs.
Well, good.
He murdered grandma by running over her with a reindeer.
Didn't see anything?
No.
Okay, now I think I'm lost.
I
found another extraction point.
I found an extraction.
Oh, motherfuck.
Oh, that's good.
If you go hit the button...
No, you can't hit the button yet.
I lied.
There's four of them in here.
I'm just gonna spin and then...
Oh, I missed.
Spinning and then...
There's a frog!
You need some help?
Oh, now I'm spinning.
There we go.
Bullshit!
Move the cart out of the way!
So I think there's two of the fucking screaming guys.
What's the screaming guy?
Once he falls over we might be able to lift him.
Okay, okay.
He gotta fall over though.
Oh, you got him!
Be careful, be careful.
I think I need help with it though.
Okay, okay.
Alright.
But it's very dangerous.
This is very dangerous.
We got this, we got this.
Oh, we might die though.
It's okay.
We got this.
It might be safer not to do that, honestly.
Wait for him to get bored and leave.
Okay.
I don't think he's gonna...
He keeps aggroing on me.
If you crouch, does he, like, lose interest?
He does!
Hell yeah.
Also, I think there's two big dudes.
Because a big dude went sliding or gliding past me over there.
And then another one came in.
So unless you manage to go in a really quick loop-de-loop, there's two of them.
Oh no!
Motherfucker's back!
I'm getting underneath the thing.
I'm up top.
Her head!
Okay, he's definitely aggroed by the light, it seems.
Yeah.
Ouch!
Are
you alive?
Okay.
I'm coming to you.
Oh, nevermind.
We can lift him!
Lift him!
I
can't see anything!
How did my safe...
What was that?
I saw a hand around the door!
Is that the...
I have 6 health.
I don't think I'm gonna make it, Limel.
I see him.
Did you grab Cinder's head?
Where the hell am I?
Limel, I'm lost.
Limel.
Oh, grandma's ashes.
Soon to be my ashes.
More like my asses.
Am I right?
Because my ass is grass.
Oh, where are you?
Oh, there you are.
I hear you.
I got lost for a second.
Okay.
Watch it.
They're coming.
Throw him away.
Oh my God.
Is the frog here?
Is that all of our stuff?
Oh, it's D.
It's okay.
It's fine.
There's only like a thousand-ish.
This is still enough.
We need to find...
Mata's head was back at the beginning, right?
I don't know where she died, actually.
Oh, you don't know?
She died ages ago.
I put her body there.
We're fine.
Okay, okay, okay.
Everything's great.
I'm keeping watch out.
And you guys, Cinder's head, okay.
We can still do this.
Easy peasy.
I don't know about that, but...
Yeah, guys.
Yeah.
No problem.
We only just make it here.
Oh my gosh.
Like $200.
Barely.
Oh my gosh.
$300.
Wow.
It was less close and then it blew up half the loot.
Yeah.
Welcome back.
Look at this tiny little stack.
It's so small.
Don't say those things about men.
The effort.
Alright.
Let's go.
Sorry.
Let's just...
Wow.
Okay.
Let's go.
Oh, I guess not.
It's a how to paint a target on your back from three other people.
Yeah.
What?
No.
I remember...
You guys love me.
There's one...
Where was the other... Oh, did you find it?
You found it, right?
Yeah, there was one kind of in the back that might be good to do.
Okay.
This way.
Hello?
I'll go press enter.
I think if I remember how to get there.
I think I remember.
But, will I survive?
That's a better question.
Hi.
The tombstone area was where?
Oh, maybe here?
Yeah.
Oh yeah, I see it on the map.
Yeah, right here.
Right here.
Oh.
Why did she do that?
Matarikon!
Matarikon, why?
She knew that we were going that way.
It's like years away too, okay?
This way?
That pinky is starting to hurt.
Hello.
I activated the one next to the base, like a dummy.
Yeah, why'd you do that?
Why did you do that?
Yep, I'm sorry.
It was a brain empty moment.
She's throwing, guys.
Did anybody take double jumps?
I bet you guys were okay.
No, I can try to get something.
Double jump.
Oh, there's a little skull guy.
Oh, they're on fire.
Frog is coming behind you, Cinder.
Careful, careful.
I won't.
I won't explode.
Who dropped your crown?
Queen.
Careful, the frog will break that stuff.
Yeah.
Let's see.
Oh, there's more in here.
Okay.
Where am I taking it?
You wanna bring the cart into where?
Here?
There?
I need you to do...
I have one health.
Where is it?
Is there anything up here?
Nothing.
Grab him.
Oh, fuck.
Oh, it's kind of fading.
It's okay, I think you can grab him.
Go, go, go, grab him.
Up, down.
I don't think it's...
Up, up, down.
Down.
I can't grab him.
Up.
Down.
Mint, it will break in one hit.
Okay, okay, okay.
Oh my God.
Place it gently in the cart.
Gently.
Up, down.
Down.
Okay.
Three.
Sorry, Cinder.
But there is loot up there.
I don't know if you can get it though.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I can use...
Throw me, throw me limes.
Okay.
Throw me to the wolves.
As Bao would say and she would come back pregnant.
She won.
Hold on, let me use a bed.
Yeah, get on the bed.
I'm finding all these tiny things.
Oh, ouch.
Oh, yeah, yeah.
Okay, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Release me, release me.
Let me go, let me go.
Yeah.
She doesn't want to let you go.
Oh, fuck.
Can you put me back up?
Oh, this is where I was hiding before.
Come on, Matara.
Concentrate.
This is serious business here.
Let me go, let me go, let me go.
Nice.
Oh, basement.
Oh, there is another extraction in the basement.
Okay.
Limes, do you mind putting me up to this, to the right side?
Like, to the other side that you put me in initially.
Is there grandma's ashes up there or...
Yeah, yeah, put me up here.
Oh, it's this room then, I think.
This one.
Do you think I can do it on my own?
We'll wait.
Don't worry about it.
Wait, I can open this, though.
Tiny item.
Monkey item.
Oops, Minky.
Minky, Minky.
Hello?
Okay, could you...
Limes, could you throw Mint to the level where I was at so I can...
Okay, be careful because the two creepy guys are still around.
One of them almost died to the bombs.
He was on the floor crying, it was great.
Mint, fold yourself down.
Rescue.
Okay, which side do you want her?
The side where I...
Oh, fuck!
Oh no.
Sorry.
Yeah, I'm sorry.
I'll put Mint up to go get that.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
What am I getting?
There's like an item...
Oh, I see him, I see him, I see him.
There's a million...
Can you lift me up, too?
Because we'll need two people up top.
This is fun.
I'm throwing up a little clown.
Yeah, careful, careful.
Let me put Montauk first.
Okay.
I think you have to go through the side.
It's gonna be easier.
Which one is Montauk on?
Can you guys tell the difference?
Give me the clown.
Which one?
It's gonna poop its nose.
There you go.
Okay, so Minty, stay there.
Okay.
And then I will...
Sorry, nevermind.
No!
Montauk!
Sorry.
How did the explosion not break the soul of the monster?
That's weird.
I'm gonna move this cart over here as well just in case they decide to come running in again.
I'm gonna try and jump to the third... Wait, can you climb up it or no?
Yeah, yeah, yeah, you can't climb.
Well, if I put Matara up there, she can lift you.
Oh.
Yeah.
I think I just fell.
Wait, where am I?
Somebody said maybe I should let Limes do it.
Wait, hold on, hold on.
I'm going back up.
You have to do it through this side, yeah.
What the heck?
A little bit higher?
Yeah, you're amazing.
Okay, I'm at the top.
Thank you.
Oh, I just...
Hooray!
Okay, do it like to me to you.
So Mint...
This is expensive.
Yeah, so... I know, I know.
That's why I wanted some help.
Grab it.
Okay.
I don't know how we're gonna do this, but...
Okay, it's okay.
Mint, Mint, Mint, put it with me.
Grab it with me.
Just like this way.
I got it.
It's not moving.
Yeah, it's not moving.
Put it up a little.
Put it up a bit.
It's like one point just... Yeah, okay.
Can we slide it down the thing?
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Let me...
Okay.
Okay, yeah.
There you go.
Yeah.
Think about every move you've ever done.
Hold on, I gotta...
I might be dead.
What?
What do you mean?
There's a lot of explosive skulls about to explode underneath me and I can't jump down to deal with them because they'll explode.
Oh my god, did they get the fucking cart?
No, no, no, no, no.
No, they didn't.
Okay.
They wouldn't do that.
It was forced.
I would've been so mad.
I need to throw you up there because there's a pink and a mint.
Like a mint...
I'm weak.
I have spaghetti arms.
We need a sexy, sexy strong girl.
Wait, why don't you both go up because I don't have any strength enhancements.
Both of you do.
Mata doesn't either because we forgot to buy it.
Oh, that's right.
I can bring the cart back out.
I'm sorry, is Cinder just watching us do this whole thing?
Sorry, Cinder.
She's probably screaming like...
Move it this way.
Oh, I see.
I didn't realize that was the painting.
Yeah.
This is gonna be fucked.
We gotta Tetris it.
Let's see.
What if we just drop the painting on the floor?
We're gonna lose a lot, but...
No, hold on.
It's kind of... You wedged it.
I just dropped on the floor.
If you show me where the painting is, I can bring the cart sort of under it.
It's like right here, though.
It's kind of difficult, I think.
I think it's a... You gotta drag... It's not a... I don't think it's a cart.
Yeah, I see.
I see.
The scary man.
Look away.
The Ooga Booga Man.
Are you guys both okay?
Yeah, he just Ooga Booga'd a little.
He's like screaming.
You hear him?
Yep.
I'm not gonna drop down until he leaves.
Yeah, do not.
Do not.
Is he still there?
I don't see him.
Do you?
What just lost money?
It's just her.
It's her.
Okay, good.
Good.
Oh, it's just her.
There you go.
Nice!
Okay.
Okay, Cinder's head is a good resting point.
We should get to the extraction point with this, please.
Yeah.
Yeah, we do.
This does not count as in the cart.
This is kind of fucked.
I'm gonna have to carry this separately.
Yeah, I'll carry it.
I'll carry it.
Yeah, yeah.
It's kind of heavy.
I'll actually... how much cart do you have?
I'll put it right next to us.
So there's an extraction point here after.
Yeah, it's the one in the basement.
Wait, there's no... I wouldn't do this one.
I wouldn't do this one, Matara.
There's a further one away.
So just leave it... just leave it here for now.
We need something else then?
I can't believe you just stared at me while...
Yeah, um, bring...
Sorry, I stared at who?
What?
Nevermind.
We need to leave the painting here then.
But we need to get something else to have enough for the extraction point.
If you throw me back up, there's a few more things.
Small things.
You can also... I actually parkoured up here earlier.
Oh, really?
Really?
Yeah, I jumped like from there onto it.
I really think... hold on, Limes.
Get small.
I'll just bring you up.
It's so much easier.
Put Mint up.
I want to try it again.
Okay, Mint, get Q.
Hold on.
Um, Q.
Don't move.
Okay, don't move.
Don't hurt me.
I already emotionally have done it.
Oh my god, you're the best.
Although it's kind of funky to get onto a bed.
Why did you put me on this side?
Is there anything over here?
Get back up.
Get back down then.
Wait, hold on.
I think I can parkour.
Just kidding.
Rescue.
Isn't this fun?
These adventures?
Oh my god, look at her.
Put me on the bed.
She put me on the bed, girl.
Oh.
She's throwing me around, girl.
Like I'm a little ragdoll, girl.
Ragdoll, ragdoll.
Stop, you're making me laugh.
Stop.
Come on, put it in.
I mean, wait.
Come on.
The bed.
You put me in the worst spot.
Was there really anything?
Yeah.
Open the cupboards.
What cupboards?
She's already half dead again.
I half killed her.
Parkour.
My grandma died long before I decided to be a streamer.
She doesn't care.
She died because you...
It's fine.
She died because you didn't learn your native tongue.
I need...
I'm not going down.
Are you okay?
Did Lime die?
No way!
Your mic is cutting out, Matara.
Oh, it's because I scream so loud.
Come on.
It's okay.
Mint?
We could bring this...
I guess we now need to...
Oh, fuck, and the frog.
Bitch.
I have an idea.
Press escape.
Escape?
Yeah, and go into self-destruct.
Why?
Just do it.
Do it.
I promise you.
Wait, something is looking at me.
Wait, why are we self-destructing?
Do it, Mint.
No!
Do it!
Okay.
Do it, Mint!
Kill yourself!
Okay!
What does she mean perfect?
You're the worst.
I'm sorry!
Wow, not even the urge to try to come and clutch.
Wait, you didn't wait.
What was this?
I thought you had a plan!
Every android for themselves.
What is this?
Everyone attack Matara!
Get Matara!
She's just laughing.
She's just...this is insane.
I've
got the sword that's maybe useless.
I got
it!
Cinder is the biggest loser!
I was so close!
That was crazy.
I wanted to be the biggest loser.
Oh, hello?
All things considered, we got pretty far.
Yeah, actually.
Hello?
Can everybody load back in?
Hey, I'm back.
Sorry, Matara went to get water.
Okay.
Oh, okay.
Sounds good.
Yeah, we got pretty far, no?
We did.
I can go for another 40 minutes if we want to do another...
Sorry, I went like super British for that one.
That was weird.
I can go for another 40 minutes if we want to do that.
We can do another one.
Yeah, sounds good to me.
Up to you guys.
Yeah.
Okay.
You know, I think this is the farthest I've gotten, like, most rounds without dying.
We're so competent.
We did a good job.
This is like the dream team, you guys.
I know.
Oh my god.
We could've gone further, but Matara decided to just end it all, I guess.
I didn't... I feel such a fool.
I thought she had a plan.
Like, okay, I'm going to put the heads in and then if I'm by myself, I can do this.
I can't believe you trusted her.
Yeah.
I think she just wanted to get some water.
Yeah, never trust her.
Actually, I'm going to get some water too.
I'll be right back.
Yeah.
Okay, I will stretch.
Okay, everybody stretch.
Oh yeah, stretching is a good idea.
You're back already?
I thought you already came back.
Man, stretching is something that I gotta remember to do more often.
Yeah, that good old pause.
You're a chick.
I heard that.
Oh, I don't think she can hear.
Thank you, chat.
Thank you.
Windows hanging out.
Oh wait, hold on.
I'm trying to get my back to crack.
I'm back, baby.
Welcome back.
Thanks.
Hell yeah.
Hello, I'm back.
What did I miss?
Welcome back, everybody.
Welcome back.
You, baby.
We're just stretching, getting some water.
Yeah, that's what I'm doing.
You girls wanna play another?
I was saying I have... I have 40... 40 minutes.
I have 40 minutes that we can do another.
Oh, let's do just a few rounds.
40 minutes?
Yeah, 40 minutes.
Please, sir, I'd like more.
Please, sir.
Let's get it.
Let's get this bag.
Yeah!
Oh my god, Limes, your Twitch bots are spamming me today.
The Miami ones?
Miami bots?
I'm getting Miami bots.
You guys haven't heard of the Miami bots?
I don't know why, but I specifically have bots that come to my channel.
And they say... they, like, say something that's, like, tangentially related to the subject in the chat, but then start talking about Miami.
So, like, because I have a plushie out and people talk about the plush, they'll come in and be like, Hey, super cute plushie.
It's really cute.
Speaking of plushies, have you heard about the unique Manatee plushie that's out in Miami, Florida right now?
It's so fucking weird.
I don't know why they do it.
Limes, can you please stop viewbotting, okay?
Okay, my bad.
My bad.
Oh, look at mine.
Wait, wait, wait.
Yo, nice.
Sounds like some cool merch drops happening.
Speaking of new stuff, did you know Miami just got a new art installation downtown?
It's now.
I don't understand the Miami bots.
I inspected you.
I'm sorry.
You guys are gonna start getting it soon.
I should stop talking about them.
They're a desperate for tourism, I guess.
What if it's actually Miami that did this?
What if Miami paid these bots to do this?
Who else would it be?
I'm really sorry if you get Miami bots.
Okay, wait, wait.
Yeah, keep going.
Wait.
I'm going.
No, no, no.
Yes, yes, yes, yes.
Yay!
Oh, oh.
Hold on, I have a very delicate voice.
Can I put that in here?
Yes.
Uh-oh, the music got creepy.
I think that might be a sting for something funny.
Yay!
Let me get this out of the way.
I'm eating popcorn.
You're eating popcorn?
I have sweet potato fries.
Yummy!
That's so good.
I love the potato fries.
I'm eating popcorn.
What kind of popcorn?
Cattle corn.
Wait, what kind of popcorn?
Careful.
Oh, yummy.
Nothing up here.
Up here.
Here, mom.
I'll bring it.
Why is the music so creepy?
Oh, there's a monkey.
Because...
You're my monkey.
Hello, monkey.
Hello.
Literally the monster into the bed.
What?
That's crazy.
How do you know it's a man?
Oh, yeah, you're right.
My bad.
I misheard.
I heard grandpa's wife.
Laser clown, laser clown time.
Nope, nope, nope.
No way, again?
Okay, hide.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Do not aggro and then later...
I'll move the cart out instantly.
No, no, no, no, no, please.
No, sir, please.
I beg you.
Grandpa's wife.
Don't get too close to his feet.
Are you fucking kidding me?
I'm gonna aggro my way.
Move, move, move, move, move, move, move.
He got everything.
Everything?
Almost everything.
He's back, he's back, he's back.
No, no, no, he's back, he's back.
I'm gonna try to get him to shoot me.
There's gnomes, there's gnomes.
Oh, shit.
Okay.
Oh, wait.
I can't believe.
I'm gonna disguise myself right here.
I'll leave him there for now.
Why is the clown so hard?
You've been gnomed.
Let's just keep going.
Such a scary place.
Oh, I thought that was a thing.
No?
They're putting in money, baby.
Oh, this is heavy and expensive.
I should not touch it.
I shouldn't touch it.
I need help.
Is he camping in here or something?
Maybe he'll like it because it's his brethren.
Clown?
Ew, that painting's scary.
No touchy.
I don't... Actually, I got lost.
He scared me so much, I lost directions.
Oops.
Oh, I need to go down that hallway.
Oh, hi.
Hey.
There's a...
Is it going good?
Oh, the clown went down that way.
Okay.
We kind of need the cart.
Where is... I don't know where anybody is.
I'm hoping they went off in that direction with the cart.
Oh, sorry.
Oh, shit, sorry.
I'm going to go bring one item back, but everything over there is really delicate.
Yeah, I saw an expensive box.
I was trying to hopefully find the other extraction point.
There isn't one on this one because it's the first map.
Oh, you're right.
There's only just one.
Yeah.
The box.
Oh my gosh.
I'm going to make this clown worthless at this rate.
Oh no, speaking of...
Okay.
You okay?
Yep.
Okay.
Yeah, I can't... He's leaving.
Nevermind.
He's being a real dick.
He left?
I'm okay.
Let's go.
Gnomes!
Fuckers.
The clown's following us.
Be careful.
Yeah, we're getting really, really unlucky.
Yeah.
Mint, you have... Oh, gnomes, gnomes, gnomes.
Try to break... Yeah.
Break him.
Break his ass.
Yeah.
What do you guys think we should do?
Die?
I mean, there's still loot.
We just need to go grab it.
There's a lot.
I can juke the clown.
She died, I think.
Yeah, she died.
Oh, I see her head.
I see her head.
Ow.
Come here.
What are you doing to me?
I'm putting you in the cart like a baby.
Come on, baby.
Come on, Minto.
Come here.
I got you a crown, Mint.
My little dumb baby.
Oh, fuck, fuck, fuck, fuck, fuck, fuck, fuck.
Shut up.
Shut the fuck up.
Oh, I think I'm doomed.
Did you get me, stupid baby?
Did you deserve me, stupid baby?
I'm stuck.
I told you to shut up.
It's fine, he left.
Ouch.
Meanwhile, he comes back around the corner.
That was so funny.
He got me too.
I'm not strong anymore.
This sucks.
No get.
What happened?
Mint, it has been so unlucky to get the clown on the first every...
Like, it has been so unlucky.
You are bad luck.
I'm bad luck now.
Hey.
Sorry.
We got super far the last time, alright?
We really did.
We passed the clown the first time.
Honestly, with four players, we're doing so good.
Look at Limelight doing it all by herself.
No, I'm telling you, so many lobbies...
Her and Giga, you can trust them to...
Oh my gosh.
Me?
When I'm alone, I'm like, alright guys, watch me kill myself.
Just leave it to the pro gamers.
I feel like there shouldn't be two enemies on one map.
Especially if you get the clown.
Or on the first map, I mean.
We just got really bad RNG.
Yeah.
You think we'll have enough?
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Let's find out.
I don't know if she knows that you guys are...
Oh no, she found me.
Nevermind.
She found us.
Yay, she loves me more.
She found me first.
I don't think she found... I don't think she's gonna find me.
No, she will, she will.
She can see you in the cart.
Oh, and there's stuff in the cart.
That's right.
No, no, no.
No, there's the crown too.
Oh, that's my girl.
She's so good.
She's my favorite small green woman.
I know.
It's okay.
Mint, you make it very hard to love you, okay?
I know.
You the same.
Yeah, I know.
I do it on purpose.
I see the color pink now and I throw up.
I feel like I'm in the middle of a lover's quarrel.
It's not a lover.
No, no, no.
A lover, no.
Yeah, my stinky girlfriend and I.
Oh my gosh, she still needs a little bit more.
Oh, she just barely didn't make it.
It would be so funny if she self-destructed.
It might actually.
It'd be funny if the clown got her.
Look at her, she's destroying these things.
Or like a new mob.
She is.
Yeah, it is a lover's quarrel, but luckily we make up all the time.
She got a fat stack.
She did it.
Oh my God, can we have five gifted for Limealicious please?
I can't believe she brought the Miami spam bots.
That's so funny.
We're coming back!
3, 2, 1.
Happy New Year!
Yo, you soloed that like crazy.
She's the best.
I couldn't let you down.
Gnomes!
Oh my God, we almost got gnomed.
Last minute gnoming.
You got gnomed!
You've been gnomed.
We can do a strength and a stamina.
Give Lime a move back for strength.
There's a gun.
Oh, we don't have enough money though.
No, that's so shady of the game to give us a gun early on when we can't afford it.
I know, right?
I think that's a tranq one though, right?
Oh my God, there's someone sitting in this seat.
That's crazy.
Ash, catch him.
Actually, we have enough for more stamina for everybody.
I love your little crown, sweetheart.
It's so good.
That's it, that's it.
It's so good on you.
Sorry, I was misreading.
You've got to stay on.
I know.
Oh, water closet.
Wait, I can go in here?
Sorry, I'm coming.
Come on, to the boat.
I'm coming, I'm coming.
I'm out of stamina.
I had to go potty real quick.
Go, go, go.
Yeah, yeah.
I like how your dumb character is just looking with their dumb little eyes.
And so you're so pretty in her crown.
My queen.
Oh, my queen.
What's going on in here?
My queen.
Do you want me to start the ship?
Yeah.
Okay.
It sounds like we're saying Michael Ween.
Yes.
Okay.
Yes, thank you.
Have a nice day.
My key.
Nice.
Oh, hell yeah.
One of you get the stamina.
Staminaur.
Cinder should have it because she's our queen.
All hail Queen Cinder.
I'm running around the house.
My queen.
Someone said, do you remember the time the queen visited Miami?
Oh, God, no.
Yeah, I don't need a health kit.
It's fine.
Can't tell if you're bot or not.
Wait, what the hell?
Oh, sorry.
I just went a little too crazy.
You are crazy.
Items galore.
Bonsai.
Chainsaw.
Konnichiwa.
This is my bonsai plant.
Oh wait, there's two now here.
There we go.
Where's the cart?
Sorry, apologies.
There we go.
We're just putting it in here?
Ok.
Yeah, just for safety.
That one...
Ok, we can't put anything else on for now.
But that's good.
Hello.
Nice crown, queen.
Every queen needs a princess.
It's because I'm a little transparent.
That's fine.
Yay.
Oh, ducky.
Careful with the duck.
It's ok, it's ok.
Just don't touch him and you'll be alright.
Can we sell him?
I can bring it back, hold on.
Oh, we got a frog situation.
Yeah, if you have a chainsaw.
Oh my god, you heard the duck.
You need to warn me if the duck is coming though.
Because he'll deliberately run into the chainsaw.
I don't know where the duck is.
Oh shit, really?
Oh, I think he ran into the duck.
I can hear it.
Who pissed it off?
The frog pissed it off.
The frog did.
Yeah.
How curious.
Maybe I killed the frog.
Can we kill the duck?
Duck versus frog.
I want the...
Kill the beast.
Oh no!
Are you Beauty and the Beast-ing right now?
A little bit, yeah.
Don't think I didn't hear that.
The frog is back, the frog is back.
Ok.
I'll get the saw, I'll get the saw.
I'm confident in your abilities to operate heavy machinery, Mint.
I have a license.
Ok.
A driver's license.
I don't even have one of those.
So you're probably more qualified than me.
Move it out further in front of you if you can, so you're not in risk range.
Oh, there's two frogs!
There's three frogs!
The duck just took damage.
This place sucks.
Why are there three frogs?
I don't know.
Hopefully they piss the duck off and they all kill each other.
Mint, you have no idea how unlucky it is to have three frogs and a duck.
I've never seen this unluckiness.
It's you.
It's me!
You're the first one.
I am.
I know I am.
Tell your mom to please bring the sand back.
She threw it away.
Your stupid mother.
Did the frogs murder Mint?
Oh no.
How's your grandma?
My what?
I guess I should bring the carpet.
Oh, she died.
You didn't hear?
Shut up.
I don't believe you.
No, I'm serious.
My grandma died.
No, wait.
After Thanksgiving?
After I visited?
Are you kidding me, Mint?
She died like two weeks ago.
What the fuck, Mint?
You just dropped a bomb on me like that.
Mint, I'm going to cry.
I'm actually going to cry.
It's my grandma.
Why are you crying over mine?
She invited me for Christmas.
She invited me for next year's cake.
I guess you just gave them time to leave.
She invited me.
Stop laughing.
I have tears in my eyes.
Mint, what the fuck?
I was like joking that we have to go see your grandmother for Thanksgiving before she dies, but...
You brought this up and now I'm scared.
Did I just blow you out of the window?
My condolences.
She's too cool.
She seemed like, again, like, obviously, you know, she's old, but she like had her wits somewhat about her.
Yeah, the brain tumor came back.
But she, it was fine.
She died in her sleep and it was peaceful.
Mint, I didn't even give her a kiss when she asked for one.
Oh, you said you were sick.
I was.
Just a little bit more.
Fuck, she asked me for a kiss and I said no.
Yes, that's fine.
Oh yeah, we're so done.
You'll see her in hell.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I mean, obviously, all jokes aside, my condolences.
I had no idea or I wouldn't have asked.
I know.
It's so funny.
I should have just been like, oh yeah, she's fine.
I had no idea, fuck.
Oh my god.
People kept saying and he kept saying grandma's ashes, but everybody keeps calling them grandma's ashes in the game.
It's just a very normal thing to say.
I know.
I didn't think it was anything.
Here we go!
I am traumatized.
I need a minute.
I'm so sorry.
No.
Do you want to tell them?
I mean, I'm listening.
I went to Thanksgiving dinner at Min's house and I was like, so by the way, how's it been?
How's your grandma?
But she's like, well, she died two weeks ago.
And I was like, no, for real.
Guys, I'm still traumatized.
I can't believe this is happening in this fucking game.
Like you as a little robot being like...
It's okay, Mata.
I ended up, I had breakfast with my family and my great grandmother was there.
And she's like, when are you getting married?
And I'm like, I don't know.
But I was making a joke and I said, don't worry, you'll be invited.
And she says, I want to be alive.
No!
Oh no.
I am experiencing loss.
Loss?
It's my grandma!
She invited me.
She asked me for a kiss and I said no because I was getting a little sick and I didn't want her to get sick.
I was giving everybody kisses and she was like, would I get a kiss?
And I said no.
She was in her little wheelchair and I said no.
I'm actually gonna cry.
Her grandma was so nice.
Stop talking about my grandma.
You smooch a picture of her.
Yeah, you can smooch a picture of her.
She invited me to Thanksgiving next year, but now I can't come.
She won't be there.
That's so sweet.
Oh, there's more frog.
More frog.
Oh, I also got this thing.
Cinder, it like caught me off guard, right?
Because she was like, oh, she died two weeks.
I thought she was kidding.
I was like, there's no way, like...
Why would I joke about that?
Wait, where'd the cart go?
Where'd the cart go?
It's back at the base.
Okay.
Oh God, that got me.
That got me.
I can't.
I can't help.
I can't believe this is happening.
In this game.
I can't believe we're having this conversation.
It's not at base.
Matara Kanyu, liar.
I can't believe we're having this conversation in this way.
It's too funny.
I'm evil?
I should have said nothing.
I should have just said she was fine.
Where's the cart?
Maybe, maybe it went this way.
Lie malicious.
The frogs just hopped past me.
There's the cart.
I found the cart.
Oh my God.
You did find the cart.
Sorry, I was moving it out of the way of frogs.
The frogs hopped right past me.
Oh my God, they hopped right past me.
They're hurting each other.
Oh, that's cool.
Good.
Uh-oh.
You good?
Diamond.
And the cart's gone.
I think it went this way.
Cart.
There it is.
I found a diamond too.
Wow.
I'm sure glad there's so much delicate loot on this level with like 18 billion frogs in it.
There's a thing up here.
I don't know what to tell you man.
I don't know what to tell you.
Oh my God, there's a frog coming.
No!
To the cart!
Save the loot!
I saved it.
We're good.
Let me go lead the frog out, ok?
But keep looking.
There's a bunch of loot around still.
He's right next to the loot!
Don't bring it here!
I'm leading him away.
Do we know where the next extraction point is?
Grab.
We gotta find it.
We can actually keep...
I think we have enough people.
To grab him?
People?
Oh yeah.
Do we?
Oh fudge, sorry.
We got like four of us.
We should be alright.
We can try.
Where'd he go?
There's two more though.
Grab him!
Up!
Down!
Ok, but watch out!
Ok, grab him again!
Grab him again!
Grab him!
In the wall!
Oh yeah, easy game.
Let me get this out of the way.
Grab him!
Grabbing.
Up!
We need all four.
I think we need five minimum.
Or like four.
No, no, we need four.
It's because she has plus two.
Ok, move him.
I got strength plus.
I grabbed him.
Up!
Down!
Nice!
Easy, easy, easy.
Grab Cinder's head.
No, it was Matara.
I'm no longer alive.
I'm sorry Cinder.
Where is it?
I'm sorry you had to find out this way.
I'm looking around.
We must be able to find it.
I will find it.
With my own hands.
Maybe down here?
Though it looks like we've been all through here.
Oh wait.
Found it!
Aha!
Who does it?
Clap, clap, clap, clap, clap.
I'll go get them.
In a moment.
Hello!
She's alive.
There we go.
Can I put this diamond in here?
So that...
There we go.
I got it, I got it.
We're good.
Nice!
That doesn't look like it carries at all.
Yay!
Be careful.
It's just some frogs.
It's just some...
Holy shit they're back for revenge!
Cinder!
Run!
I'm OK.
Oh yeah, I'm dead.
Just let me...
Is anyone alive?
No,
please.
OK!
Wait, Lime!
Lime!
He's so cute.
I had to Lime.
I'm sorry.
Let's go!
Oh my God!
I thought you guys were dead.
I thought you guys...
Hello!
That was crazy.
Every single frog came down there like, remember us?
I know!
How are you on time Lime?
Yeah.
Got time for one more.
One more round and then I had to go.
That's OK.
We should get a double jump for someone...
so that they can get to those higher places.
You should get double jump.
For no reason other than it would be funny.
Extra jump.
And stamina.
Well, we should like spend all our money, right?
Because...
Who wants a tumble launch?
A tumble launch?
Me, launching you into the sky.
What's a feather drone?
Oh, it makes items much lighter.
I guess it's unnecessary if you're packing strength.
Yeah.
She's got them guns.
Oh, can I also steal?
How do I rotate by the way?
Somebody asked me to rotate.
Hold right click.
Wait, medium.
Is there a large?
Medium.
She did!
Alright, start the boat.
Wait, who's starting the boat?
I can start the boat.
You're busy stealing, so I'll do it.
I'm not going to heaven, baby!
I'm the thief!
Wait, which one is the jump?
Blue.
Oh, thank you.
Make sure you have at least 50 stamina.
I got 50 stamina.
We're so back.
We never left.
Let's go stealing!
They'll patch it out.
Somebody said it would be funny if when they patch it out, it just makes you explode.
Do they penalize you?
Yeah, that would be good.
That's better than fixing it.
Wait, what?
Oh, there's the other door.
Oh yeah, this is...
This is just a long hallway.
Such a crowded house.
What's that?
Buffalicious, oh yeah!
Put it in.
I got something else here too.
Oh, look at you with the little jumpies.
I know.
I'm putting my thing to use.
My thing to use.
Well,
they probably would if you didn't eat them.
I found another TV!
Where is...this way?
I don't know where the cart is.
I'll take that TV back to spawn.
Don't worry.
I got you.
Yeah, take it back.
Take it boy, thank you sir.
Yeah, take it real good.
What's around?
Actually, I think I'm lost.
Guys, I'm lost.
Is this to spawn?
I think so.
Yep, I knew it.
Silent Hill fucking music out here.
I know!
What could it be?
What could our creature of the week be?
I hope it's a gooner.
You won.
Oh that's why I didn't know, because I didn't go this way.
Another television?
That scared me.
Grandma!
There is a big snowy man in there.
I forget how you like... I think he's just very slow and like...
I don't know what he...
He didn't hurt me.
How do we... how do we...
How do we fight him everybody?
What the fuck was that noise?
What was that?
What was that sound?
Oh, it was the fireplace?
What was that noise?
It's a big snowy man.
Oh, the marshmallow man?
I don't know.
Is Martha alive?
I wanna see the baby!
Yeah, the don't look baby.
I wanna see the don't look baby.
You can look for like half a second, but then you better look away.
Baby.
I don't hear him.
Oh!
Is it the giant head?
Wait, was it the guy at the top of the stairs?
Is that a baby?
I thought that was grandpa.
That's not the baby.
Can I have someone carry the other end of this statue?
This is rough.
Oh, that's... that's Joe Biden.
Not this way.
It's not this way.
I've been dead the whole time you guys.
I'm having more popcorn.
We're watching a TV show everybody.
To me, to you.
Wait, Mint's head?
Did they find me?
Don't you girl me.
That was a joint effort.
Lift it up a little bit.
It's sliding.
They found the head.
Okay, you wanna swing right.
Swing right.
Oh my gosh, this is the worst part.
Careful, careful, careful.
We're trying to Tetris your furniture in.
Thread the needle.
Beautiful, beautiful.
To my side, to my side.
Okay, it's just 10k worth of value we've managed to knock off.
Who's we?
What do you mean who's we?
Who's carrying the other...
Wait, wait, wait.
Don't do that.
We'll cap.
That's cap.
Motherfucker.
Okay, I'm gonna...
Let's put everything on...
Is Mint dead?
Just in case, let's go try to find her to make sure.
Let's keep this card with us.
Because we're gonna take it to the next point.
One second, don't...
I can't really tell some of the monsters apart.
Well, I've never seen the baby.
I hope I see the baby.
The head.
Where is my little stinky girl?
It'd be so crazy if a scary ghost came out of the walls.
I mean, popcorn.
If only there was a ghost that could jump out and go BOO!
I don't know where the fuck she is.
I fear...
There's a lot more loot here as well, but Matara took the card.
Yeah.
Mint, baby!
Where's my little stinky girl?
That scared the bejeebies out of me.
What is she doing?
How are they not going down the hallway that I died in?
Oh wait, I died right here!
I think she's dead.
Wait, I died in there!
They just didn't notice.
That's where I died!
They didn't notice my head!
I'm extremely bad at driving this car.
You're extremely bad at everything, MataraCon.
And my head was in the closet!
I died in the closet!
Where's all the monsters?
It's like they gave up after they killed me.
I saw it all.
And it's all on my stream.
Where's my stinky little girl?
Mint!
If only there was a stinky little girl!
She's so obsessed with me!
I can't!
She's definitely dead.
They're not going to find my head.
And then I won't be able to play the rest of the game.
Oh, hello!
Not up there either?
The other extraction point is right ahead down there.
Okay.
There's that at least, but...
I appear to have lost the cart, and Mata, and Mint.
I can't even see it on the map.
No, that's it ahead, right?
I think I just found Mint.
Yeah!
Wait, are you kidding me?
I went in there and I didn't see her!
She's probably laughing at you.
She's laughing at you.
I'm not even here, so...
Okay, I'm going to do the first extraction point though and get Mint back.
She did it on purpose.
Okay.
I should eat real dinner.
Girl dinner!
Marshmallow man.
What is he...
What is he aggroed on?
Wait, there's something else in there.
What?
What was that?
Share some for us?
You wouldn't want it, it's stale popcorn.
Unless you like that.
What about babies?
I think he can see you, I'm not sure.
It's okay.
Ding dong!
Lost so much money.
Oh my god!
I'm...
I'm alive!
Hi!
I'm so glad you found my body because Matarou...
Did you see the marshmallow fighting the baby?
That was weird.
What was that?
Oh shit, shit, shit.
That's the marshmallow.
Is he fighting the baby, you think?
Maybe.
Shit.
Oh, he's coming, I think.
No, he's not.
I'm gonna check.
We're okay for now.
I'm gonna grab the money.
I don't think I'll ever see the baby.
Oh, let me heal you a little bit as well, hold on.
Oh, thank you.
There you go.
Alright.
Oh, I can't get used to the sounds yet.
I'll let you lead since I'm not sure where to go.
Okay.
If you open your map, you can actually see the white box...
Oh, that's right!
Yeah, thank you.
Marshmallow's in here, careful.
Okay.
Can he hear me?
Did he just turn around?
No.
Okay, we're good.
Okay, come this way.
I'm coming.
Okay.
Matara Khan, you blind old roach, what the hell?
I think we just escaped with what we got.
We got a lot of money.
I need help, I need help, this is heavy.
Our sack of cash is too heavy.
Put it deeper, put it deeper.
Okay, step back.
Oh gosh.
Money, money!
That was a close one.
That was really close.
Let's go.
I'll never see the baby.
I wanna see the baby.
It got vacuumed a few times, it might honestly have died.
Oh, that's true, yeah.
It's in there, the marshmallow man and the baby were fighting.
Yeah, I was like...
Oh!
Motherfuck!
How did it get me?
I don't know, I'm sorry, I was flailing around there.
That was fucked up, I didn't even know he was here.
I know!
That's what got me before, but yeah.
It would have been nice to know.
Oh, sorry.
It's fine.
I was dead.
You know, that guy sucks, he's so aggressive.
I didn't know he was here, the marshmallow man blew me into him.
No!
Cinder's got this, Cinder's got this.
Matara is singing.
Oh well, Matara at least can leave if we all die.
I'm glad this game doesn't really punish you for losing your other teammates.
Does she know the way?
She should know the way because it's marked.
Yeah, they're good, they're great.
I heard a baby.
Yeah, the baby's around.
No, I don't!
I wish there were mimics in this game.
That would be awful, but funny.
I feel like with how much stuff you pick up, they'd have to have a tell.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I don't know if they saw.
We were dead, we were dead.
How'd you die?
The big head.
How did he...
The marshmallow man blew me into Joe Biden and then Joe Biden ate me.
That was fun!
It was!
Thank you so much everybody!
Thank you guys for organizing!
Yeah, thank you!
I'm glad we didn't end on a loss.
No, of course not.
No way!
Are you kidding me?!
I didn't think we could actually die in there.
I didn't think so either.
We could, we could, but they need to say goodbye.
I guess we could say goodbye on Discord.
Get it closer to you, get it closer.
There we go.
See you later, everybody.
Kill yourself wise.
Yay!
Thank you for organizing, Stender!
Thank you very much everybody!
We were able to have fun and hang out!
Thank you!
And maybe we can all do something again another time.
Let's do this again soon.
Is anybody still streaming for a bit?
Stender, are you?
Okay, me too, darn it.
I'm all stoked because I have to pack.
Okay, well, it was awesome.
You got so big for your box!
Alright, bye girls!
Have a good one!
Bye-bye!
Thank you!
I only got the kiss, Stender.
Get out, Catboy!
Bye-bye!
Yay!
I died a lot.
I died so many times!
That was a lot of fun.
I like that game.
There are so many different monsters.
I never got to see the baby.
Try checking the mirror?
Solo run?
Nah, I think I'm done.
Actually, DMC has to get moved tomorrow.
To a little bit earlier.
So it's gonna be a midday stream for me.
So I'm gonna be heading out!
Thank you for all the gifted memberships, you guys!
Thank you for all the donos!
Sorry, it's hard to read.
Especially in a game like this where you're like...
Paying attention the mostest, you know?
I was like... My brain was like trying to figure out...
But I think by the end I really understood it.
Except all the different monsters.
Does the tutorial tell you what all the monsters do?
I don't know.
It's okay.
It's expected of during a collab.
But I had a lot of fun.
Hopefully I can play this game again.
Since it's the hot stuff right now.
I wanna play it again sometime.
Maybe with this group or another group.
Or whatever, whatever, whatever.
Yeah!
Otsumito, everybody!
Wow, my chat froze at the very last second.
Oh, there it goes.
Yay!
Gomintou, thank you!
Otsumito, Otsumito, everybody!
Have a great day, have a good night.
And I'll see you when I see you!
Next!